uh
um to do with the application in running
welcome everyone to this afternoon's
planning committee meeting before we
start I would like to confirm which
committee members and officers are here
thank you chair
um in the meeting room with us today we
have councilors William Armitage Andrew
Cooper Mark Foster Heather Liggett who's
substituting for uh councilor Carol
Huckabee
Mo pots Alan Powell Tracy reader Jackie
Ridgeway
Kathy Ralph Diana Ruff yourself who's
joining us on the chamber at Mill Lane
and councilor Ross Shipman
apologize I'm just going to assist
somebody who's just joined the meeting
and also um also wise we have members of
the governor's team who are supporting
this meeting
um we have a legal representative Jim
Fields ends with us today we have Adrian
Kirkham who's the planning manager and
Emily and Susan who are who will be
representing the the planning team on
applications
thank you thank you chair
as you know we have a protocol in place
for meeting in this virtual way which I
would like the meeting facilitator to
Now read out
thank you chair
um so this is just a reminder to all
members to dress and behave as if we
would do if we were in the council
chamber at Mill Lane Please be aware
that this meeting is being streamed and
recorded throughout
um I'm going to just hit the record
button now so that we can create um an
audio recording of this meeting you'll
hear an announcement
this meeting is being recorded
a further reminder to to all those
present to speak through the chair these
remain muted when you're not invited to
speak and to indicate to speak please
write speak within the chat bar and you
should have your closed captions enabled
and I'll be able to communicate with you
via that and also through the chat
function uh to help assist the chair um
who should be able to see if people are
indicating to speak but if not I will
assist her to be able to do that when
you are speaking members if you could
introduce yourself so for example you'd
be counselor X representing why Ward
voting for each application today will
be completed by roll call please be
mindful of your home surroundings please
appear alone when on camera and keep
yourselves on camera at all times
thank you chair thank you
first item on today's agenda is
apologies for absence have we only
received any further ones
uh chair uh Portuguese today have been
received from councilor Jane Barry and
councilor Carol Huckabee who's being
represented today by councilor Heather
Liggett
thank you
the second item is Declarations of
Interest members are requested to
declare the existence and nature of any
disposable preconi interest and or other
interests not already on the register of
interests in any term of the agenda and
withdrawal from the meeting at the
appropriate time have we received any
declarations
councilor had a look it is indicating to
give uh to give the Declaration
yeah
I should be speaking against the
application 20 forward stroke zero zero
five three five forward stroke FL
stretton thank you uh so does that
indicate then counselor um that you'll
be leaving the meeting after you've
spoken and answered any questions from
members and you're speaking in Your
Capacity as a ward member yes that's
correct okay thank you
foreign
thank you
item three minutes of the last meeting
we now have the minutes of our meeting
held on Tuesday the 15th of December
2020 are we happy that there are a
correct record and is there a mover I
move it
thank you
all those in favor
any against
karisha
thank you
this is where we move on to the main
business of today as you can see we have
four applications Each of which has its
own report marked as items four to seven
I am happy with this and intend to
consider them in that order
however before we do this I would like
the clerk to explain for the benefit of
members speakers and the public who are
watching on YouTube how they will be
dealt with
all right thank you chair uh this is the
procedure to be uh for considering
applications at the meeting
we will consider the four applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
although there will be a break between
them
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and the link has been sent to committee
members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its YouTube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any Ward Members First followed by
objectors then the applicant or their
agent to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views using this
conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the speaker
questions if necessary in order to
clarify any points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee and
determination by a vote
a note for speakers
once the application you've come to
speak on has been dealt with you may
leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain then please mute
your microphone and turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
are you aware this meeting is being live
streamed
the council will make a recording for
the purpose of preparing the minutes
once of the minutes have been approved
by the committee then this recording
will be deleted
please note however that others may also
record the live stream from the internet
thank you chair thank you
let's move on to the first application
in line with our normal practice I'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments reports
that have been produced and for the
planning manager to give a brief
presentation showing photos and plans of
the site
the meeting facilitator will share the
presentation on screen this means that I
might find it difficult to see everyone
therefore I will allow the officers to
complete their presentation I ask
members to reserve any points of order
or questions about the process until the
end there will be plenty of time for
questions the first application is that
ashover hay which is Ned
2400484 forward slash FL
thank you
ask Emily chair if I made to to go
through the presentation with members
and to provide a brief conversation on
the application thank you
when you're ready Emily thank you chair
slide please
if I could refer my list to like
comments where we've received Consulting
comments from Barbershop Wildlife labor
residence and the agent we've also
received a further late representation
today from a Mr Gore in the list at a
neighboring property at Walnut farm and
they're concerned about drainage ecology
trees prior to their own property and
that the only person who would benefit
from the development would be the
applicant
full permission is sought for the
construction of an art building for the
storage of a tractor and Implement and a
log store for the upkeeper the land
associated with the barn
adjacent to Walnut Barn is that the next
slide please
thank you
the application slide is highlighted in
Orange to the center of the screen and
as a point of reference is slightly
between ashover hay in the West
and Stone Rose Lane to use
cut the next slide please
thank you
the location plan identifies the
applicant's land holding of
approximately 2.5 acres the site is
bounded by fields to the East and
Orchard to the north and a conversive
Stone Barn conversion known as one bond
in the south
next one please
thank you
here we have the block plan which
illustrates that the proposed building
would be closely associated with the
application building cited approximately
meters to the east
the building is supposed to be oriented
at 90 degrees and it's then an extends
4.5 meters Beyond existing dry stone
wall
could have the next slide please
thank you
this next slide shows the floor plans of
the proposed building which would
measure maximum dimensions of 6.6 meters
deep by 6.8 meters wide with a ridge
height of 4 meters
the tractor and implement store part of
the building would measure 6.6 meters by
4.5 with a ridge height of 4 meters
whilst the lock store would measure 6.6
meters deep by 1.8 meters wide with a
ridge height of 3.8 meters
we have the next slide please thank you
this plan illustrates the elevations of
the proposed building which demonstrate
how the levels have been utilized on
site
building would have utilitarian
appearance finished in in vertical
Timber wall cladding the tractor and
implement store would have a corrugated
metal roof past the lug store would have
a natural slate roof covering to match
the main application building
thank you
this first photo has been taken from the
public right-of-way number 84 which is
located approximately 90 meters to the
west of the site in an elevated position
on the ridge of ashover hay
the proposed building would be cited to
the center of the photo where the
Caravan can be seen at the present
photos stick around the same spot but
zoomed in just for a better view of the
site the building fold of the Caravan is
the building which has converted to the
dwelling whilst the building to the
right hand side is Walnut Barn a further
have the next slide please
thank you
here we have a service photo taken from
ashover hay Ridge this shows the
traditional ribbon development of
ashover hay and Mr
dwellings that's the next slide please
thank you
again this is a further photo taken from
the ridge the application site is to the
far left of the photo oxen Reservoir can
be seen in the background for references
provided over about a kilometer away
um and to the right hand side of the
photos of field where public footpath
number 83 runs in a diagonal route from
walnuts Farm towards dark Lane to the
South
the next one please
thank you
this next photo is taken from Public
public foot path number 83 within the
field as mentioned previously looking
towards Walnut Farm to the north
proposed building would be located
behind the tree to the center of the
photo
we have the next one please
thank you
this photo has been taken from Stone
Rose Lane which is to the east of the
application site looking back up towards
Ash overhead
to the proposed building which would be
cited within the center of the screen
where the Caravan can be seen at Frozen
have the next slide please
thank you
this slideshow is a favorite photo taken
further along Stone Rose Lane looking
back up towards the application side in
the distance thank you
here we have a photo taken from Ash over
here outside the access point to the
application site to the right hand side
of the bit to the right hand side is the
building which has been uh well it's
been given consent to be converted the
proposed building would be cited by the
Caravan is cited
we have the next one please
thank you
this is a further photo from the access
point of Ash over here two field
accesses can be seen the right hand side
would be used to access the proposed
building
lastly this photo is taken from outside
Walnut Barn looking towards the
application site
thank you that is the end of the
presentation thank you chair thank you
thank you Emily um like the speakers to
speak as the clerk explained they will
each have three minutes to get over
their points they will be informed when
30 seconds remain as members you can ask
them to clarify any matters that have
been raised but remember your question
should only relate to the points which
have already been made
if the technology fails us we will have
asked them to send us in advance written
statements for their comments
those that we have received have been
included in the agenda supplement I'm
going to read the speakers in order that
I have them on my list what I will ask
for speakers is that we do not have lots
of repetition because we have quite a
few speakers cancer Armitage your hand
is up
uh yes uh uh it was the matter of the
wildlife report do I take it that we
haven't had one
I can just answer that chair if I if I
may yes the comments made by the
Darbyshire electricity Emily's mentioned
in her
update chair are in that pack and just
run to cancer armitage's question check
no we've not sought nor received an
ecological report from the applicant
I'm happy to take further questions on
that about the issues it may or may not
raise Jen now or later depending on
yourself and how members wish to
understand that issue as far as officers
are concerned could I uh
comment on this that without this report
uh we have to have this report before we
can proceed with the planning
application uh because uh it's part of
the law uh would you uh
say I would really go for a deferment of
this whole uh application because it's
not in place
okay I'm happy to come back now as I say
or await to further instruction from
yourself if you wish to address this
issue further into the the application
consideration share I can certainly give
you the office of you
okay let's have the office of you before
we proceed the advice
um for the to the consultation response
from the Darwish Wildlife Christians as
I say within the pack that members have
received and in that members will note
that the doctor like trust are
advisement prior to the determination of
the application it is recommended a
preliminary ecological appraisal is
undertaken and to assist members we've
included in the pack the relevant
paragraph from circular 06 2005 but the
darshan wildlife trust also set that out
in their confrontation response from an
office point of view chair we've sought
further advice from the planning
practice guidance and again that's set
out in the advice we've set out to
members in the update which talks about
um needing such surveys where there is
significant or large-scale potential
impacts on ecological interest
and from the view of officers a building
that is measuring approximately seven
meters by seven meters chair is not one
that is likely to have those significant
impacts and certainly the view of
offices is that to place the applicant
at the position of having to undertake
such a survey of considerable expense in
terms of an application of this small
scale is not considered by officers as
to be appropriate or proportionate in
this instance indeed Sheriff we were
seeking such appraisals on developments
of this scale located in the countryside
across the district we'd be asking them
for on a great many applications and not
just one was uh in in this location
chair and that's the view that we have
as officers that in terms of impact on
ecology if there is any it's very
limited in scale and subject to an
appropriate mitigation strategy could be
addressed through condition and that's
why we brought the matter to members for
consideration this afternoon chair just
finally just to address the issue that
cancer Armitage has raised regarding
potential deferral
that is an option open to members if the
committee believed that they don't have
all the information necessary to
consider the application but in doing
deferral at this age chair it would be
indicating to the applicant this is the
only issue of concern to members and
there would be a suggestion I think in
that deferral that deferral was on that
basis only and subject the potential
addressing of the ecological interest it
could be taken by the applicant that all
of the matters are addressed share my
advice to members would be to hear the
speakers and consider the merits of the
application and if you consider that
ecology is the only issue at that point
that needs addressing then that would be
the appropriate time if members
considered it such to seek deferral for
that additional information then we
would bring the matter back for
consideration of that issue only but
following consideration of all the
matters chair members may have other
elements of the application that they
may wish the applicant to look at and so
that that could all be done in one
element in one package rather than
potentially coming back to to members
that suggestion that all matters other
than ecology were addressed and the
expectation that subject that
appropriate mitigation that the
application would otherwise be
acceptable so so that's the basis of the
officer View and why we've considered it
appropriate still to bring the matter to
membership first of all officers believe
that members do have all the information
necessary to address all issues and if
they are concerned about the localized
impact of ecology a condition could
address that but also chair in terms of
the general concern or consideration of
the application we believe it is
appropriate to continue discussion of it
this afternoon yes yeah I think that's
right uh in terms of the determination
obviously members will do that based on
all the evidence that you've heard and
read today so I think actually although
that remains an option it's something
that perhaps you'd actually want to talk
about later I am following the um both
the speakers evidence and also the
further discussion with officers thank
you chair thank you councilman Foster
uh thank you chair I'd like to support
what council Armitage uh has said about
a deferment uh I understand what Mr
Kirkham said and I do do take that on
board but for me I'd like to look at
this all together if we defer this I'm
not deferring it just for that reason uh
alone that we don't have the wildlife uh
report but I'd like to look at the whole
lot together with the wildlife report
rather than
hear all the speakers and take the time
up uh of this committee and then it come
back later on just for that what I'd
like to do is look at the whole lot
together and the wildlife report is part
of that information I wouldn't want to
start making the decision or have an
opinion before we see all the
information so for me to make sure I
like the whole lot in front of mate so I
had support and second uh that from
Council Armitage
thank you chair thank you
I promise to admit I'm very tall because
I would like to hear all the speakers so
we could gather the evidence
um
yeah if I may
um councilor Shipman then counselor
these speakers have probably took time
off work and done all sorts of things to
come and speak today it seems rather
ludicrous that we'd defer it before
we've even heard all evidence when we
could easily make a decision today
thank you councilor reader uh I have to
say I agree with councilor shipment I'm
quite shocked that we're having this
discussion now usually the running order
of the meeting we would hear the speaker
speak in first and then councils would
have the opportunity to ask questions of
the officer and then we'd have all what
we needed to make a decision of whether
we defer at that point so I don't think
I would support councilor Armitage and
councilor Foster on this occasion I'm
sorry
no fine
I've made my decision I'm going to go I
want to hear what the speakers have to
say and then we can make a decision
afterwards sorry gentlemen but I do feel
as strongly as the other candidates and
people have given up their time so I
think we'll start with the speakers
okay yeah I'll go along with you
we can start with councilor Mike Thomas
from ashover Parish Council
can you hear me Chad
you can you've got three minutes Mr
Thomas
starting now good afternoon now I'm
representing uh the views of Russia or
the parish council our objections to the
application as follows uh firstly the
wildlife survey which has already been
touched on uh Derbyshire Wildlife
trust's response to the 4th of January
States this application lacks any
ecological information prior to
determination they recommended
preliminary ecological appraisal be
undertaken in order to establish the
habitats present and determine the
presence or absence of protected species
such a server to be undertaken prior to
the determination of a planning
application
we understand this is an obligation
statutory obligation windows down and
departure from this requirement can only
be allowed under exceptional
circumstances we've not seen any
evidence as such and with respect don't
feel planning department has the skill
set or authority to override this
obligation
second ground levels no details of
levels are being provided that we're
concerned that the ground levels may be
substantially altered and this
compromise how the buildings would
harmonize with the appearance of the
site and the surrounding special
landscape area
third construction of double-skinned
walls is unusual for an Agricultural
building now as the plans no longer show
cavity walls these could of course be
reinstated in future aligned to this
concern is the fact that the plans show
that substantial foundations remain
together with block work rising to the
height of the roof which is unusual for
an Agricultural building
both previous conditions imposed on
applications
1601227 should be carried forward for
example under condition 3 storage
buildings ancillaries to the primaries
of the site would be detrimental to the
character and amenity of the area
contradicted policies gs6 anyone ne2 and
R9 so why has this condition being
ignored in considering this application
finally our service neighborhood plan
the planning officers rightly recorded a
series of policies within the Asher of a
neighborhood plan where this application
falls short these are AP 1 2 11 13 and
16. time doesn't permit the opportunity
to go through each of these at turn
demonstrating the associated concerns
however the fact that so many policies
are referred to Highlights the degree of
concern especially relevant are that the
development would be visually intrusive
in the special landscape area the
building is not of an appropriate scale
and couples with previously 10 seconds
remain it does represent a loss of
privacy for neighboring properties on
this basis we object to the application
thank you have we any questions
councilor Armitage
yeah uh perhaps you could just briefly
outline the uh policies which have been
uh of the ashover neighborhood plan uh
which have been uh what shall I say uh
not really uh featured much in the
officer's report
okay
um I think it would be fairly time
consumer I mentioned um uh policy one
for example that was the um
the first one
and um in this respect we're talking
about the shape and form of the relevant
settlement
um the scale which I've already touched
on as an issue and that particularly
requirement there is a skill which
reflects the size character and level of
service provision supplement and doesn't
adversely affect the neighboring
Properties by way of loss of privacy
daylight visual intrusion or immunity
then there's two which is development
proposal outside the the limits of the
development
[Music]
um
so I think that
stands alone is now supporting the rural
economy needs to be in the countryside
affordable housing the sort of um
so it's outside the settlement
development limit and also uh it's uh
it's in a special landscape area within
a special landscape area within uh
outside the settlement development of it
yes it is indeed right and then we're
going to
um uh policy um 11 which associated with
design and I've touched on this the the
distinctiveness the scale how it
harmonizes with these with the
surroundings
um then the under there's a 13 and
policy 16.
and 13 is um landscape character and of
course and indeed I believe the other
objectors that is a key issue
um ensuring that uh there isn't an
unacceptable visual intrusion
um how does the affecting landscape
elements so that's just a a flavor of
What that particular one's about and the
final one is about dry stone walls so
that was a specific issue here I did
notice within the planning office's
report that there's um there's intended
to be an offset whereby the demolition
of one war will be offset by the
construction of another one somewhere
else but uh what this policy is about of
course is uh is ensuring that drystone
walls are retained and currently the
form part of the character of that area
which is going to be compromised
councilor
are there any further questions
no thank you Mr Thomas
move on to the next speaker uh Emma King
hello Emma you have three minutes
starting now
DWT unequivocally recommended a
preliminary ecological survey prior to
determination of the application citing
paragraph 99 of circular 05 2006 these
are statutory obligations regarding
wildlife and planning by failing to
survey prior to determination these
statutory obligations the nppf numerous
pieces of gov.uk guidance are being
ignored this leaves any decision open to
Legal challenge of the reasons given for
ignoring the recommendation to survey
prior to determination not have any
basis in policy guidelines or law the
first reason given is that the
development is so small it will not be
of detriment this is not supported by
any evidence something big enough to
need planning permission is potentially
big enough to have an impact on Wildlife
especially in a wildlife Rich area such
as ashover hay only trained ecologists
can determine impacts and an ecologist
from the DWT already agrees professional
surveying is required here furthermore
additional specific species-specific
surveys are merited by habitats and
local records not size of development
for example the gov.uk guidance on Great
Crested newts are protected species
states to survey if there's a pond
within 500 meters which there is it's
not negated by size or or small
developments nor is it negated by
plastic herons or goldfish in
contradiction to the first point there
will be no impact the planning officer
stated she was aware newts were likely
to be present and would therefore write
the new surveying mitigation into the
planning conditions according to
Circular 2005 2006 leaving surveying to
planning conditions is only for
exceptional circumstances of which there
are none since the planning office is a
gnosticologist they cannot envisage what
requirements will be needed to further
assess impacts mitigate and as the case
may be licensed prior to the studies
being complete it's therefore impossible
for planning conditions to be set
without professional assessment it's not
sufficient to merely assess under the
nppf mitigation and enhancement of
biodiversity must be in place the
applicants have not attempted any
mitigation or enhancement the report
cites a new dry stone wall a suitable
replacement habitat for common lizards
however there's actually no new dry
stone wall in the plan and no ecologist
has verified that this is acceptable
mitigation to summarize consortees the
law policy and guidelines stated that
ecological surveying prior to
determination was necessary surveying
would have established species presence
the impacts of development and aided
mitigation of those impacts instead the
application report contains guesses as
to the forthcoming requirements
including any required by law since the
application fails to demonstrate
appropriate surveying for mitigation of
an impact on an enhancement of wildlife
permission must now be refused
thank you have we any questions
councilor Armitage yes counselor
uh thank you chair uh you heard uh What
uh Adrian Kirkham had to say what uh
what to conclusion do you conquer from
that
Emma could you hear the question
uh yes is that I I wasn't sure if that
was directed to me yes yes
sorry what what Mr Kirkham had to say Mr
Kirkham hasn't asked for any reports uh
he doesn't have the information in front
of him to be able to assert that
there'll be no impact
so he's not able to conclude that uh
furthermore there's he can't guess as to
what the mitigation might be and it also
or the planning department also have
failed to address the question of
enhancement of wildlife
um which is
um required under the national planning
policy framework uh paragraphs 174
yeah if I may uh please just just just
come here in here I'm seeking to advise
members in the best information that I
have
um and I think that the issues around
the
validity of the information I've given
to members I I believe will be best
discussed by members when it comes to
that debate rather than
a suggestion chair at this point that
the information I've given to members is
inappropriately I think that's a
discussion that would be best
okay for discussion with members at the
appropriate pointing chair thank you
main argument given is that it's it's
small but I'm saying that it's not size
that determines the gov.uk guidance the
guidance states to survey regardless of
size of the development it doesn't
exclude small developments
okay thank you are there any more
questions
no thank you Emma next speaker is Andrew
King
good afternoon Jack
good afternoon you have three minutes Mr
King my assertion is that the proposed
development is not an agricultural
building this is for the operation of
use appropriate for its location I
comment on evidence derived from the
application and related case office
report the report reference 2.6 the site
is located within open Countryside which
is designated to the special landscape
area
my comment local plan GS 1.6 guiding
principle in the countryside is that
development should both benefit economic
activity and maintain and enhance the
environment
case reference 2.7 full commission is
sought for the construction of an
outbuilding for the storage of a tractor
and implements in a large store for the
upkeep of land associated with the bar
comment other than elevations drawings
revised CE is received by the Council on
13 at 30th November 20. the application
makes no reference to this being an
agricultural building
bond which is the existing building
within the site previously approved on
16th of Jan 17 is a mixed-use building
or tractor store at stable Jack room is
situated close to the road show the tail
Lane was adjacent to Walnut Bar this
building now has planning consent to be
converted into a four-bedroom dwelling
planning reference 20 double o double
four the existing use of the site which
includes the behind mentioned above
confirmed by the applicant at section 14
of their application is domestic with
land use to allow for keeping of courses
an activity not normally qualifying as
agricultural unless the horses were used
for working the land or farm for meat or
hides and seek the government keeping
horses on farms at the reference report
reference 8.35 the planning officers
recommend the restrictive use condition
that the building should not be used in
connection with the running of a
business this will militate against the
likelihood of any economic activity
being directly associated with the
proposed building that is to be situated
in the countryside conclusion there
appears to be no evidence put forward in
the application that any agricultural
activity is being undertaken by the
London and furthermore the certificate
of ownership certificate area the
funding application has been completed
declined that land has no agricultural
tenant hence the land has no father this
in turn must cast serious doubt over the
principle of development in open
Countryside particularly seconds
remaining that's section 8.8 of the
officer report in principle an
agricultural building on this site is
considered acceptable as the development
is for the operation of a use
appropriate for its location
consequently it is asserted that this is
merely an outbuilding to a domestic
dwelling house not an agricultural
building and has no place in open
Countryside thank you
Frankly Speaking are there any questions
no thank you move on to the next speaker
and Martin Howe
there you go
okay thank you very much
thank you uh I'll confirm my comments to
uh planning matters and factual
references Mrs Cartwright's report lists
five applications uh recently on this
site uh this application makes six out
of a total of 19 recent development
applications put before this Council by
this applicant
an application for a tractor store and
Stables on this site was granted in
January 2017. condition three of that
permission States categorically no
structures should be allowed on the land
connected to the application
unfortunately the tractor store and
Stables was not built as per their
approved plans and from day one it was
used as a domestic garage
three years to the day later application
was made to convert this three-year-old
track to store
in perfect condition and in full use
albeit is a garage to an extended
four-bedroom dwelling
this was granted by Mrs Cartwright
referring to fears of over development
should any further development be
applied for on this site
12 weeks later this application was made
for a further tractor store and stables
and originally identical in size and
construction to the one recently granted
permission for a dwelling
the site is in fact full and this
Greenfield site was the only option left
open to the applicant if you wish to
continue development numerous amendments
and even a change of title followed with
the pretense of horses only being
dropped on the very last day when final
revised plans were submitted
they were very strange for people who
have chosen to live in the countryside
to object against the building of an
outbuilding of proportionate size and
construction which is Justified and
which has proven proven to be required
by the applicant due to having the
equipment listed on the application form
what I'm objecting against is that this
proposed building meets none of the
above
the building will be within 20 meters of
my boundary not 46 meters as in the
report and will impinge on my privacy
and enjoyment of my own property
in addition the existing track to store
and Stables soon to be a house we'll
have an upstairs window directly
overlooking my property and that is five
meters from my property
there is no justification or need for
this building and therefore no merit in
permitting its construction
remember the applicant has already
claimed the same justification once
before on this site
that building was constructed like a
house
was constructed like a house with cavity
walls used initially as a garage and now
soon will be a house
that is not a supposition that's fact
there are no tractors or farm implements
on this site either now or in the
preceding three years when the previous
building was available for that purpose
guidance says I must not talk about the
possible future development of this
business however if built at all I can
say what I think this building will not
be
not be at the tractor store and Stables
thank you Mr Howe have we any questions
Council Armitage
yeah
but he could just touch on the fact that
the Privacy Factor uh of of your of this
application as it regards to your uh
property
well as I said the the the property the
existing building uh that was built as a
tractor store and Stables is five meters
from my boundary that is so shortly to
become a house uh and that has a window
shows a window in the Gable end
overlooking my property
um the
building site that I live next door to
has been going on for five years now
since the original
um conversion of Walnut bond by the
developer uh Mr Bedford and also then
the building of the tractor store and
now we have this further application on
the Greenfield site for a what is termed
to be a uh now it was a tractor store
and Stables uh it is now just a tractor
store and uh and log store and implement
store
I think the the point overriding
everything on here is that there were no
farm implements or tractors or horses uh
involved in the building of the first
tractor store in stables and exactly the
same thing is happening here now
so there's no justification at all so so
there's no horse on this site at all uh
the first building was built uh the
application forms a tractor store and
Stables uh it was obvious when the
building went up that there were to be
no horses uh because the building was
not built as per plans because the
stable doors although showing to be
stable doors from the outside and
opening at the top and the bottom were
in fact solid on the inside so any
intent for horses there was uh was not
proven
it was used from day one as a garage a
domestic garage for the uh world of barn
development and then three years later
as I said almost to the day a brand new
building uh the application was done
three years ago so it took say took six
months to build so a two and a half year
building was then applied for permission
to turn into an extended four-bedroom
dwelling the cavity walls in that
building you know it was built as a
house it was built you know ready for
construction uh ready for conversion if
you like it was easy to do
I'm afraid this building with its huge
foundations
um supposition I know and looking into
the future but it's a building with
foundations uh that are proposed that
are Far and Away over engineered for a
simple agricultural building
right thank you very much
thank you how any further questions
now if we move on to Susan Howell
oh just give a moment we're on the same
feed chair so uh we'll just have a
moment
hello hello when you're ready Susan
three minutes
right
there are any number of valid planning
reasons to refuse the further
development of this site into a
Greenfield Countryside setting
the ashover neighborhood plan has been
adopted by any DDC and is now the
Bedrock of their planning policy for ash
over Parish
the government statement on this says
the establishment of a plant gives local
people the opportunity to have their say
in local development
on two occasions now over 30 local
people plus the parish council are
voiced concerns and indeed some of these
are based on previous development on
this and other sites operated by the
applicant and these concerns do appear
in Mrs Cartwright's report
in addition all the following policies
are quoted as being material to the
decision-making process
sustainable development open Countryside
landscape character special landscape
area protecting and managing features of
importance to Wild flora and fauna
development affecting nationally rare
species General design principles
surface and fire water
Highway access and the impact of new
development development in the
countryside
biodiversity and geodiversity
food risk and drainage high quality
design and peace make placemaking
in addition the ELP policies ss9 and
sdc3 seek to safeguard this Countryside
from inappropriate development having
looked at the above policies and also
having read Mrs Cartwright's report it
seems the decision to conditionally
approve his base only on the fact that
there is a certain land holding it seems
that the applicant does not have to
actually own a tractor or farm
implements or prove agricultural
activity to gain planning permission for
such a building on this site for a
second time the crucial difference now
is that this latest application is on a
Greenfield site
you say that conditions will be attached
but who will ensure that these
conditions are enforced it has been
shown that conditions attached to
existing buildings on this site have not
been adhered to and have not been
enforced
will any conditions now be strong enough
to ensure that possible future
applications for change of use
extensions remaining hard standing
lighting Etc are refused and can
planning committee guarantee this
this building has no justification and
therefore no merit thank you thank you
are there any questions
no thank you Mrs Howe thank you move on
to the next speaker Philip Wilson
chair Billet Wilson is not on this call
um Alan can I just confirm that he
doesn't meet the criteria for having his
speech with that read out
the criteria uh is that um the um
speaker should have attempted to log on
to the meeting and had difficulties uh
being able to access the call so on that
basis
um just for consistency I'm not sure
whether we would be able to read this
out the speeches however within the pack
so members will have had the opportunity
to read it and assess it as part of
their decision-making process today
okay thank you we'll move on then to
Elaine Bagshaw
good afternoon chair good afternoon you
have three minutes Elaine when you're
ready thank you
it is a special landscape area and our
search any approval must demonstrate
cognizance of this
after reading the planning office's
report it appears that the main reasons
for granting conditional approval are
based on the applicant's rationale for
the need for Secure Storage from a
screenery and implements to maintain the
area of land of approximately 2.5 acres
as a previous London I appreciate the
need my for this myself
however in this instance I consider the
need to be overstated
the building is variously referred to as
a tractor shared and implement store at
one point is The Stables and now is an
agricultural building
the land itself has had change of views
from agricultural land to equine use
with restrictions on the erection of
additional buildings I have been unable
to get clarification from planning as to
what the current status of the land is
the planning office's statement in 8.8
is incorrect the applicants carry out no
agricultural activities on this site
indeed in section 14 of the planning
application the applicants themselves
state that the land is for domestic use
and for the keeping of horses they have
no agricultural sized
um tractor or equipment indeed for the
past six months the applicants have moan
all of the land area with a domestic
ride on mower at least twice a week an
activity which is changing the condition
of the land from agricultural or equine
to domestic Garden status
the planning officer refers to an
existing building at the nearby Walnut
Farm as being similar to that list being
proposed by the applicant and this
building is considered not to protrude
into the landscape
the building at warlock Farm is used to
provide Secure Storage for a domestic
ride on mower under the maintenance
equipment for a very similar area of
land two and a half acres the building
has a secure storage area of 12 square
meters with a ridge height of 3.3 meters
built below but away from the same
original field wall that the applicant
plans to demolish the building at Walnut
Farm has been fighted that it's barely
visible in the landscape
the proposed building however will have
an overall footprint including the log
store which is an integral part of the
building the 41 square meters and a
ridge height of four meters four times
the size of bat at Walnut farm for the
same level of activity
it requires a demolishing of an ancient
field wall it has very substantial
footings in addition to a concrete pad
it will have internal walls of concrete
blocks to roof height plus external
Timber cladding and requires significant
ground excavations the appearance of the
building bears no resemblance to any
other building in the vicinity apart
from the one that they now have planning
permission for for conversion to a
dwelling
because of the lack of agricultural
activity on this site there is no
justification for a building of this
size and scale and design chair thank
you thank you are there any questions
cancer Armitage
[Music]
uh thank you chat yeah uh could you just
uh reiterate about the fact that there's
uh no that it's been used uh not for
agricultural use uh the land out uh as
it's being cut uh with a ride on mower
uh I mean I'll take it uh there are no
implements or uh tractors that are
needed would I be right in this
absolutely correct it's a domestic ride
on no no it doesn't even have a
collection box and the applicants have
been mowing the land at least twice a
week which is far in excess of what
would be necessary anyway
um on if it was to be agricultured for
land or even equine land I know there's
no other Machinery associated with it
they've done no hedge trimming
um they do do some streaming around the
edges which is not great for wildlife
because it destroys the the long grass
edgings around the fields
um it is just a domestic field and it's
being turned gradually into a garden
uh thank you for that
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you Elaine and excuse me chair
Mr Wilson has now uh joined the room so
I suggest that you uh take his speech
now okay that's fine
yes good afternoon are you able to hear
me
yes we can Mr Wilson
okay sorry I'm just trying to work from
an office over in in Europe okay so yes
um I have made representation before to
officers by means of um of two letters
of objection
um the specific
um comment today relates to the um
vehicle access to the site
um and the fact that the vehicle access
to science is very dangerous
um the alterations on the site have
related sorry have been up have been
made numerator cases the original
vehicle access to Walton Farmers it's
sorry to
um
to want to warn up Farmers it was has
been
closed off no entrance to Walnut Barn
which is now separate from this
application was made which is just how
good sight lines but what is now being
called Hey up which is the
um the garage contact room whatever it
was supposed to be called it's now being
turned into Bungalow to which this
application relates is using what used
to be a field Gateway which is it is an
obtuse angle to the road and the sight
lines are non-existent from that point
and I don't feel that highways have made
proper
um have properly on a properly assessed
nor understood the the fact that any
vehicle coming out of the property is
safe is is not causing a danger to other
users in fact in my own experiences I
put in in the text that I've put forward
to this meeting uh we're aware of two
instances where one a cyclists was
almost knocked off into
um Walkers were by the emergency
vehicles from the site
from past experience of Mr Mrs bedford's
activities I have no confidence that
this current building which is
supposedly not going to have any hard
standing
um will be used for anything other than
further further vehicles and they also
have
unfortunately uh precludes an area of
turning space that was previously laid
out in the application made earlier in
20. 20 relating to the um to the
conversion of the former Tap Room
stables and
um storage which because there's log
store now
um spans across
the vehicle parking and turning area as
well as the field behind so I think
one the current application is having an
impact potentially for even with even
further judgment but the main point is
that we I want highways to revisit the
whole concept from the entrance to the
road that that's my point
I don't think that it's been properly
properly it's been properly covered up
thank you Mr Wilson are there any
questions
no thank you we'll move on to the next
speaker Alison Sparks
thank you
Mr Wilson if you could
um
um close down your camera as well please
thank you
hello Allison you have three minutes
when you're ready
hello yes thank you
um I submitted an objection in July 2020
and also a revised objection in November
2020 and I made three points I asked is
it domestic is it agricultural is it
equestrian and I'm still asking the same
question I'm really not clear about the
status of some of this the log store
part of the application sits within the
cartilage of the proposed four-bedroom
house and this has been domestic land
since 2013. the tractor store part of
this application sits on land which is
outside the cartilage of the planned
four-bedroom house so the land on which
the tractor store part of this
application says is no longer
Agricultural and has not been
agricultural since change of use was
granted in 2016.
um none of the land in this application
is agricultural there is but there are
still several references in the officer
report to it being agricultural building
and also references to a hold end
um
in terms of the historic content which
is my second point the proposed building
would be detrimental to an historic
landscape and would be contrary to
policies ap11 this is of the ashover
neighborhood plan protection of ancient
enclosures and overall visual intactness
ap13 that refers particularly to field
boundaries and settlement patterns and
ap16 then with specific reference to dry
stone walls of the ashova neighborhood
plan which is a material consideration
The Proposal is to straddle and
therefore demolish part of an existing
dry stone wall
the dry Stone will
um potentially illustrate the
post-medieval and or 18th or 19th
century pattern of field enclosure in
this area and is a an historic
demarcation between the buildings which
are in the ribbon development of ashover
hay all the buildings tend to be close
to the road and the open land in the
enclosed spheres behind that Rhythm and
this development will affect how the
historic landscape landscape is red
um all of the views of the historic
pattern of settlement would be altered
by this development jutting into the
open Green Field
it's beautiful far around in terms of
the visual intrusion into the last game
there are lots of policies which have
already been referred to by all the
speakers about
um
there is obviously
yes certainly thank you again reference
to policies AP 11 13 and 16 AP 16 of the
neighborhood plan from the hay and from
the whale back you would look straight
down upon it and see it jutting out into
the open Green Field from hay Lane and
from the path by Walnut Farm you see it
jutting into the open Green Field from
Stone Rose Lane you'd see it from below
drifting into the open Green Field and
none of this would be mitigated by the
construction at lower level which is
probably about the time chair from
online thank you Mr Sparks
um okay thank you have we any questions
no fine thank you we'll move on to the
agent Ian Goodwin
10 Mr Goodwin is in the meeting room um
I've just given a prompt to
to speak
Mr Good Mr good and either
[Music]
Mr Goodwin you're on mute
hello hello Mr Goodwin you have three
minutes thank you it is noted that
councilor Armitage had requested the
application be considered by our members
due to the impact on the landscape in
looking at the planning offices report
and the start location plan attached a
lot to draw to members attention that
the
site location plan is wrong that's our
location plan shows the initial sized
proposal the initial proposal had a
footprint of 4.2 meters by 8.1 meters
has been significantly reduced to a
footprint of only 6.6 meters by 6.3
meters wide paragraph 2.8 incorrectly
measures of the building at 6.6 meters
deep by 6.8 meters wide it is 6.6 meters
deep times 6.3 meters wide so to put
this into some form of context it may
help members to visualize single
garage-sized building on a land holding
of 2.5 acres
paragraph 8.8 confirms this is a
reasonable amount of land to justify The
Proposal
paragraph 8.11 also notes that the
building will not protrude any further
into the open Countryside and the
neighboring agricultural building at
Walnut Farm not a farm it was a type of
error there in the report
I have to say it is sad that immediate
neighbors have enlisted an army of
people far and wide in order to try to
stop this very Modest Proposal
whilst at the same time hay Cottage are
in the process of major building work to
alter a three-bed house to a five stroke
six bed house
hey House of previously converted and
out building and sold it on as a
detached dwelling
desperate comments have been made about
the wildlife and small garden pond at
Walnut farm this Pond was approximately
was made approximately three years ago
by the previous owner it is rubber lined
as a plastic Heron it was stocked with
goldfish and it is Upstream of our
proposal therefore our proposal has no
impact
an ecological survey requirement is not
appropriate for this very small scheme
Mr Kirkham has already explained that
there is no significant 30 seconds
remains
and if counselors push this requirement
for this very small scheme then
basically many many planning
applications will have to have one this
will place an unnecessary burden on
development throughout the district
hopefully members will be able to agree
with the recommendations of their of
their own planning officer and Grant
planning permission thank you thank you
are there any questions
councilor Armitage
yes uh thank you chair uh
is this an agricultural building or not
we seem to be uh in a dilemma here uh
considering that it's outside the
settlement development limit it's in uh
open Countryside and it's in a special
landscape area so can you tell me why
and is it agricultural
yeah the sole purpose of the bill then
uh my instruction from my client is this
building is the Secure Storage for
equipment to maintain that two and a
half acre land holding
the the only part of the building that
was in the residential cartilage as all
the people have touched on and it's the
log store which really I put on to to
soften the excuse me
which I put on to soften the building
from the view from the uh from Walnut
Barn
um so it straddles a little bit cancer
Armitage you've got the log store on the
cursive side
um and then on the uh on the
countryside on the field side you've got
the implements Choice it's a secure
implement store the local constabulary
are problems with of rakings and
Equipment being pinched this is a secure
building it's single skin block work
it's softened with Timber cladding so it
fits in it flows with the natural levels
of and
I can it will be a tasteful building
inappropriate for issues foreign
which was Secure but it decided then to
make it into a house
you know I I can't really understand it
as the the reason and also the log store
you could get half a forest into that
it's massive
it increases the footprint by must be 30
percent
well
[Music]
you can turn the log store off I mean
it's on to have a
house but it is is this
is this for this building or not this
log store you seem to be uh at a mess as
to uh what its exact purpose are well a
lobster is for keeping logs for the
heating Appliance for the new house
or for the converted house there's yet
to be started on silent
although it's outside the settlement
development limit which you've already
admitted
the log stores in the cartilage of the
of the consent that's been already
issued but the conversion
right but this consent for the log store
hadn't been given at the time
we've got planning for the conversion of
the existing Outlet to make a four
bedroom
property
from the agricultural building which you
are doing formally
uh could you tell me the significance of
this Pond a plastic harem
well there's been a whole host of
objections there's been an army of
people against my clients on this one
goodness knows why
um and outlandish
comments have been made uh comments
where
I I know where the where the come from
and I know that it's from sometimes a
lack of understanding on building
construction well that's a whole nother
ball game but
there are issues everybody jumps on
people people will talk about oh great
crested news uh bats uh barn owls they
all think it's a lever to get into you
guys to try and stop something that's
happening and and and basically it's
um
he's nasty it's not and in this case
it's not appropriate for this building
as Mr Kirkham has already
uh clearly sad
that if somebody wanted to try and
justify because whatever's going
to try to refuse this because there's no
ecological it's it's frankly Beggars
belief
uh I've beg to differ on that but there
you go thank you Chad
thank you are there any further
questions
no thank you Mr Goodwin thank you
colleagues we've now the opportunity to
put questions towards the planning
manager and other officers about this
application
again I would like to keep this part of
our proceedings focused on getting
clarity about any of the points that
you're not sure of alt counselor I can
see your hands up and counselor legit
uh
questions it's
it's true and Emily but it's also
asked him a question as well is it
appropriate to ask that or would you
rather me wait
can you just wait stop finish reading my
program we'll never be up yeah okay so
I'll make a list I've got uh
Tracy had a
and Ross yeah
okay once we've done this we can then
have our discussions about the
application based on all we've heard and
read for that reasons member I would be
grateful if you could not move any
motions at this stage let's wait until
we've had a chance to make our
assessment and to ensure that this
happens and avoid any confusion I've
asked the clock to highlight this point
if anyone indicates that they wish to
move a motion before I've said that I
would be prepared to take them
okay in the same rules apply please move
your microphones unless you want to
speak
so at the end of the debate
yeah it will be now questions to the
planning manager fine so
Trace did you want to start
if that's okay so Adrian and Emily I
just wondered if I could just make sure
that highways of checked all the access
points and everything I know it says in
the report that it's utilizing an
existing access point but as far as your
concern there was no concerns with
regards to the access to this eye and my
other question would be with regards to
the materials being used for the
building you feel that it's in keeping
with the area with the timber cladding
and the roof you have no concerns with
regards to what what the building is
made out of
um you don't feel that it's going to
sort of you know really visually impact
on the area from that kind of
perspective and my question to Jim if I
can just kind of ask it all together and
then you can
sir
um it was um one of the objectors who
mentioned Jim regarding the ecological
survey and opening ourselves up to Legal
challenge so I was wondering if Jim
could kind of put me a little bit more
in the picture with regards to where we
are legally with regards to that if
that's okay chair fine Jim do you want
to start
[Music]
you're on mute still
okay so I think
it might be useful if I um
read out extracts from the
the document that was referred to the um
that
it was circular
I think 05 I can't remember the the
um
the reference but it was the
um section 99 from that circulum
which uh states that
um
I'll read out the relevant sections it
says it is essential that the presence
or otherwise a protective species and
the extent that they may be affected by
the proposed development is established
before the planning permission is
granted
otherwise all relevant material
considerations may not have addressed in
making the decision so that it's it's
recommended that there should be a
survey
however it goes on to say that bearing
in mind however bearing in mind the
delay and costs that may be involved
developers should not be required to
undertake surveys for protective species
unless there is a reasonable likelihood
of the species being present and
affected by the development
therefore
that means that there's not an absolute
requirement where there are species to
um to have a survey
um and if the council believes that due
to the the nature and the scale of the
of the development even if there are
species present that the actual
development is unlikely to affect the
species then there is no requirement to
um uh require a survey to be undertaken
and I think that this is precisely what
Adrian has stated at the start of the of
of the item I think he was saying that
due to the scale of of the the actual
um development there is no requirement
in this case to uh uh to undertake or
require a survey to be undertaken
therefore
if we don't have a survey we will
it's we're not it would not be an awful
not to have a survey so I think
hopefully that answers your question
regarding whether we would be in trouble
as if we didn't have a survey or not the
answer would be uh no no we wouldn't if
if it is was reasonable to come to the
decision that the um
the development is unreasonable to have
an effect on the uh on any species that
is present
thank you Jim is that okay Tracy lovely
thank you and just the other two points
that I raised with Adrian and Emily yep
thank you Adrian Emily
thank you and we'll just answer your
question councilor reader um in terms of
the highways and Highway 40 days and
infections have been principal today
um it's not considered that this
agricultural building would be
intensified
you know the access onto the highway
Emily I'm sorry you're breaking up there
could you actually get a bit closer to
the mic yes sorry can you hear me now
yes can yes
and so it's the heart the highway
question is all and the highway 40 came
back and they raised no objections in
principle
um for the specific use applied for on
the basis but it supports this
surrounding controlled land
um and the the introduction of an
agricultural building is not considered
to identify the use of current access on
the highway
um and then in terms of the design
um it's of of an appearance it's
appropriate for its purpose and it's
also
um would be contributed of materials
similar to the agricultural building
that is seen at the neighboring property
thank you
Adrian
yeah thank you chair I believe that um
Jim and Emily have answered the question
I guess the only the only other point
I'd make in terms of
um comments that Jim made on the need or
otherwise the survey chair members will
recall that the outset I mentioned the
advice and the planning practice
guidance
and I know this is in the pack that was
sent out to members yesterday but in the
that guidance it does say that the
ecological survey will be necessary in
advance of a planning application it's
the type and location of development
could have a significant impact on
biodiversity and that was the point I
was making it yeah I would say which
Jim's just referred to a building of
this size is certainly not in my opinion
likely to have a significant impact on
biodiversity purely simply by the fact
it is a small scale building
thank you
is that okay Tracy
yeah okay Heather
yeah a question for Adrian please uh
could you confirm what the status of the
land is is it agricultural equine or
domestic
interesting in terms of that chair
members
um I've seen from the history that
missions previously been granted for the
use of the land for the keeping of
horses so it has that Tech stamp use
which in any case any land may be used
for agricultural purposes at any time
without the grant of planning permission
a change of views to a use for
agriculture is not development so that
could take place at any point in any
case
can I can I just ask something else um
is it not required if you if you're
keeping a field moan extremely short do
you not need to have change of views to
domestic because that's sort of turning
into a garden
in terms of the planning use of the land
no not necessarily no the the issue
about use of the land is distinguishable
from the appearance of land and for
example
um members will know of instances where
Turf is farmed for example and that has
a significant difference to where
um cows are kept for example it is the
use of the land that is the determining
Factor rather than its appearance
thank you
Rose
thank you chair I just wanted
um some Adrian or Emily could confirm uh
there seems to be
references to this being a area or site
of special interest
um or landscape or something is is that
true is that not true
just to sit down and Emily can
correct me if I'm wrong chat the the
site currently has set out in your ex
stunt development plan is located in a
special landscape area
that designation is not transferred into
your publication draft
local plan so it wouldn't have that
designation in any adopted plan should
the publication draft go forward as such
but in the current plan yes it has
designation as a special landscape area
just just in terms of that I guess the
consideration is
is is different but fundamentally the
same in the special landscape areas set
out in your development Planet there's
no preclusion on development there's not
a an absolute no to developed in special
landscape areas but it should be
designed in an appropriate way and in
effect the policies in your publication
draft local plan are are similar to that
in the respects in the ass that you
develop respects the character of an
area and and that takes on a landscape
character assessment in any case so
there's a special designation currently
that isn't transferred to your
publication traffic local plan but the
consideration Remains the Same you need
to be satisfied that any new developed
in those areas is appropriate and in
keeping with the character appearance of
those areas
thank you are there any further
questions
no okay
thanks to the officers for that this
leads us into the final part of the
process our discussions about what we've
heard what we think and what we want to
decide before we're doing any further I
would just like to ask the clerk to
remind us about motions
Alan yes thank you chair
um please bear in mind members that
emotion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
if an amendment to emotion is moved and
seconded then that Amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who's moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving emotion against
member recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject of a recommend
officer recommendations fails or in
other words it is not passed that
doesn't mean to say that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further Motion in
favor of the recommendations or another
course of action this will need to be
approved by the committee through
another vote
in terms of the timings of the Motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee is heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
motions to be put
if they wish to propose a motion
Council reader
well thank you chair well
we've had reference uh about from the
agent about people from far and wide
the majority of the people who spoke
today
uh from uh Usher hey
so uh that disproves that uh
the it's out it's in the special
landscape area this uh building no
matter how big it is uh we've had uh
buildings uh
in the special landscape area turned
down before
it's also outside the settlement
development limit and it's an Open
Country Part Countryside and uh you know
it's a gs1 is uh specific on this
also it's against uh the ashover plan
and the neighborhood plan which is uh
it's
uh well uh inspectors have said that
great weight has to be put on this uh as
in uh ap11 AP 13 and ap16 which says
about AP 16 says about the dry stone
wall now these dry stone walls
Arrangement uh monuments to say because
it's the all to do with the enclosure
act which was brought about
uh in medieval times and all of the uh
actual dry stone walls in that area uh
are protected on ap16 doesn't matter
about them switching from one to the
other it's the fact that they are
actually moving them which is an ancient
Monument as such and I think you should
take you know uh note of this and yes
all right we're coming back to the uh
Wildlife study I don't agree uh with
what's being said
it's in the laws we've got to be done
I'm bearing in mind especially a special
landscape area and it's outside the
settlement development limit and the
agent said that really because of the
size of it it didn't matter but I'm
sorry there are uh protected species in
there uh and then he uh you know you've
got to do the job properly and it's
against a law not do we're not talking
about what other people think I live in
the countryside and I've seen protected
species there's all sorts of in and
around that area we just mentioned bats
there are bats in the whole of Ashoka
Parish used about uh but and you have to
take note of them we're not in the
middle of a town well although in the
middle of London I understand they've
got peregrines but anyway we're in
ashova Parish and as such these animals
have to be uh after we taken account of
and it's no good just sort of brush
pushing it aside because people don't
want to be bothered or the cost Adrian
the cost what cost are you put in on
online on Livestock on Wildlife you know
I think I think you just brush it aside
with no care whatsoever and I think you
should really uh look at the blue planet
and see what other people have to say
experts not what you think we should
take note of the experts not
people who know nothing about the
countryside
so
can I move a motion oh sorry chair um as
you actually said earlier
um the child has yet to open up
um the debate or finish the debate and
open up the floor for motions counselor
okay I'll hold fire
thanks Laurita
yes chair I'm sorry I find myself in a
position where I'm disagreeing with a
little of what council Armitage is
saying
I'm quite sympathetic to what is
happening with the uh you know the
ecology side of it had a similar
application in my area for Clay Cross on
Clay Lane we passed that application
despite having all of those concerns uh
Council Armitage around that ecology so
I am very sympathetic to that part of it
so what I'm going to ask Adrian is at
the beginning of his presentation he did
talk about possibility of putting a
condition in there which supports that
and I would be um you know open to
listening I've listened to everybody
today that's put forward their views and
it's it's reaching that middle ground
where you know you think something could
be made acceptable and I haven't heard
anything in terms of evidence that means
that this couldn't be worked through
possibly with a condition around that so
that is my view
thank you
councilor Foster
oh Council Adrian do you want to say
something first
uh no chair I just wanted to attract
attention just ask if I could come in
and inappropriate time please okay
councilor Foster uh yeah thank you chair
um
yeah
um my concerns here my first concern is
it doesn't like look like we've put a
lot of weight on the ashova
um neighborhood plan without me going
through all those policies I think uh
Council Armitage touched on on most of
those and the rest
are in
uh in our Pike well the the policies
that concern me because it's not about
feelings and I'm sorry about uh Council
of readers comments bringing in the Clay
Cross one from last month I can see the
relevance though
I could see the relevance I could see
how you might feel but it's not about
that this has to be looked at on its own
as not uh not as in a reply to a
previous one uh previous uh one that
went through
I can't hear you I'm sorry Tracy uh so
what I'm looking at is actual policy now
if we look at the existing and this is
not a motion but if we look at the
existing uh local plan that we've got in
place we've got uh the details we've got
there uh the policies that concerned a
gs6
uh which says new developments in the
countryside year six does it uh does it
satisfy the requirements of this policy
now for me a building of this size and
scale and design and the new
uh the new dimensions of 0.6 6.3 yeah
take that back but I'd have to look at
either the previous uh
the previous Dimensions or the the New
Dimensions which we're told of which we
don't have but we've had them uh from Mr
Goodwin uh so a building of this size
scale and design GS gs6b in keeping with
the character of the countryside for me
for what I've heard it doesn't keep in
character the countryside that's the
first one gs6f
it does not represent a prominent
intrusion into the countryside again I
believe it does
be1 General design principles a
respect the character and appearance of
the surrounding area I don't believe it
does that either
any two special landscape area this um
this proposed building is in a special
landscape area a it would not materially
detract from the surrounding landscape I
believe it does as well so that's gs6b
fb1 a n e 2 a
anyone landscape character the very
distinctive landscape character of The
District should be conserved uh and or
enhanced uh I don't believe that this uh
concerns that so that's it's not an
opinion that's actual policies there
which I'm quoting and if we've got a
record of that later on at the
appropriate time I'll make a proposal
based on that not this time but at the
appropriate time based on those it it's
quite clearly does not meet any of those
quite clearly thank you chair thank you
councilor reader
I just want to make sure that everyone
is clear
ing these points across I'm absolutely
not making this decision in response to
a previous application I was drawing
similarities so I just want to make sure
that Council Foster is is clear on that
that I am not doing this in reply to
another application and basing it on the
all the evidence that I've heard today
thank you okay are there any other
comments councilor Shipman
right
I've gotten to be honest I am actually
gobsmack but Council Armitage and
councilor Foster so against this because
inconsistent with previous decisions
they've made they have voted for
applications of similar sizes extensions
um out buildings and never once
mentioned or asked for a wildlife survey
on the property a building of that size
we're talking about a small development
here obviously some people might have
found that that's that's an issue and
then what you know they're here and
saying they'd be safe but we have to
reject someone from planning reasons and
going in the same thing we need a
wildlife survey
um
you're going to get crucified in front
in front of the inspector because the
law is quite clear unless it's in that
which is why our savior unless it's a
large development or a special
scientific interesting area of special
scientific interest then that would
greatly you'd be to get a wildlife
survey but clearly
this is not the case here and therefore
that discretion has obviously been
applied to this on weekend as a
committee apply that to this development
so I don't think that's an argument at
all
um and again the the issue raised around
the change of use from the other
building that's close by
this committee has a responsibility to
either stand by the decision that was
taken at the time to convert that
can't then be held against another plan
application that comes in further down
the line so although it's you know it's
a worry that it might get converted it
should a future application come in
before us I mean I'd reject it if it
were foreign basis of as what's happened
previously
um but I wasn't on the committee when
the conversion was done I don't believe
I don't know so I for me
you know I can't comment on that aspect
but I know that given it's a it's an
agricultural building oh that's what the
proposal is we can put conditions on
this approval make sure it's solely used
for that
um take into account that you know if if
the reduction of the log
um
part of it as the agent says that could
be reduced off of it if that will help
the objectives uh in reducing the size
of this um
this building then perhaps that's
something else you could do but let's be
honest come on Council Armitage and
photo there's no way that we can object
given the fact that we can condition
such things
um that have been raised as concerns
during this debate
thank you councilor Foster yeah just to
bring some clarity to that
um yes I wasn't mentioning only at the
very beginning to mention about the
wildlife report before I heard any of
this so that I wanted to have all the
information so here I'm not asking for
that information what I mentioned was
actual specific policies I've uh I've
gone through all of those already so
it's those conditions and it's not not
related to any other decision made at
another planning committee this is a
specific one all these policies uh
actually for this for this application
on the
uh thing uh it's special landscape area
and its outside settlement development
limit and it just so uh in the rules and
regulations that no uh development
should take place unless it's something
very very special and I'm afraid I don't
believe that this is uh the other thing
is agricultural does this uh have an
agricultural holding number which all
Farms are supposed to have
councilor Shipman
yeah just in terms of um what um says
about the appearance sort of thing this
has been this is going to have a warden
outer layer on it and it's got a slight
roof
that is as in keeping as you'll get or
somewhere and uh that's out the
settlement
um Bound for it
um in terms of the special landscape
that's not an official thing that
triggers the wildlife survey it has to
be a scientific an area of scientific
interest
which might be where the confusion is
and this unfortunately doesn't fall
within that
um because we would literally be asking
um applicants to get one every time they
wanted an extension on the house if
we're talking about
uh you know for this level of
development
um which is unfortunate you know this
clearly people that are against it but
we have to be consistent because you
will the next meeting and Council Foster
an armatures will be against a
development or for a development that's
got the same criteria and they'll vote
the different way I just don't think
that we've got to be consistent I'm
sorry
okay I'm going to take two more it's
Council Armitage and councilor fostered
and I think we'll round you up because I
think we're just going over and over the
same ground but for clarification
Council Armitage first yeah I'd just
like to uh correct uh Council shipment
on the fact that a slate rule mentioned
that uh it's a tin roof uh of Jackson
profile or something uh and it's the log
store which has got the uh the other uh
a slate rule
the Jackson profile which is this
plastic coated uh uh profile tin uh but
it's the other the log store which quite
frankly could uh house a forest uh which
has got uh uh a slate rule so you know
just read the things and you'll see and
uh coming back to Tracy let's let's put
about the other one because I'm going to
say it
that was a plan which was approved by
your uh party at the last thing and you
should remember that you approved it it
went out to referendum and you should
have questioned it then and that's when
it is
[Music]
thank you chair I'll make it clear for
the last time I'm not mentioning
anything about Wildlife survey here that
was at the very beginning none of these
policies I've mentioned
gs6b
fbe1a and e2a and any one are relevant
to that survey it's not about that these
are specific policies which I'm
objecting to uh this proposal not again
not in case you forget Council shipment
a wildlife service still not
okay thank you I'm going to bring Adrian
Kirkman at this point and then we'll
open it up for motions
thank you chair just um to to address
some of the points that um cancerous
against the Foster have made if I'm May
and then then one more General point the
the policies that have been cited both
in terms of the neighborhood plan and
the council's local plan as I said
previously don't preclude development
from taking place but you need to assess
the development against them so that's
that's the correct assessment chair and
members will need to take a view on that
whether the building is in character or
not whether it's prominent or not
whether it's designed acceptably or not
but just to be clear they don't the
policies don't actually preclude
development taking place and
specifically the policies in the
neighborhood plan again don't preclude
the the loss of stonewalls for example
they just ask that they be taken into
account in the assessment that's made
um just in terms of the the policies
that specifically councilor Foster
mentioned chair he mentioned a number
gs6 B1 ne2 ne1 and it members are minded
to support refusal based on
adverse impact against those policies it
would be useful to have some clarity is
it the location of the building its size
the materials used Etc as to why there
is specific consideration of
contravention so that would be helpful
just one final Point here which I think
is quite important to make in terms of
the comment that cancer Armitage made
regarding ecology
I just want to to be absolutely clear
chair that I'm not saying that in any
instance ecology isn't important or
doesn't matter and none of my officers
who work with me would take that UI that
we fully accept the decology is an
appropriate material consideration and I
would just like to ensure there's no
confusion that officers don't consider
ecology important we do but in all these
instances chair we need to put that in
context and all I've sought to do is
advise members based on my understanding
of the law and the guidance that is set
out for all local planning authorities
to consider which I've mentioned this
afternoon chair thank you thank you
Alan would you like to go through the
process now for motions before I open it
up for uh uh yes chair essentially it's
uh along the lines of which I said just
before but
um if there's going to be emotion uh it
must be moved and seconded if there is
an amendment to the motion uh and that's
moved and seconded then that will be
taken first as things stand Joe there
are no motions so um if you open up the
floor
um it would be down to members to uh
move and second a suitable motion thank
you chair
thank you right the floor is now open
for a motion yes
yeah could I go against the officer's
recommendation
counselor Foster
okay I'm trying just one second only got
one hand uh yeah I'd like to second that
and uh give the reasons for going
against that motion uh going against
officers recommendations uh Mr Kirkham
uh asked for uh some feedback on uh the
building and why so we've got gs6 b f b
e one a and e2a any one I'm happy to
read those out and go through them
um if other other members wish me to
explain why I'm happy to do that but
I've read through them once
um and as for the building of this size
scale and design for either size either
the one that's included in the pack or
the new one of 66 666 meters six by six
point three so the tablets are having an
effect now they're just kicking in
um it's the size scale design and
location
so all four of those Master cabin so I'd
like to second that motion of Mr amateur
uh Council are you happy with those uh
those reasons I put forward I haven't
included
um the ashover neighborhood planning
that
well I think we should AP 11 AP 13 and
ap16 uh about the dry stone walls
thank you Asian Kirkham
yes thank you chair I've got policy gs6
B1 ne1 ne2 and as cancer Foster's um
helpfully set out his scale size design
and location of the specific Elements
which is helpful we've also got um I
show enabled plan policies 11 13 and 16
and in terms of 69 as that specifically
refers to the loss of stone Wars whether
members if they are minded to support
the recommendation whether they would
want to the loss of Stonewall
specifically added in as to the the
reasons of unacceptability and and
finally chair if members are minded to
support the recommendation I would
suggest
um that you add in the relevant
complementary policies from the
publication draft local plan that are
consistent with gs6 B1 and anyone in the
resolution that counts the fastest put
forward
so just a stone wall issue and then the
whether
um members are okay with us adding in
the the complementary policies from the
publication draft chair
thank you councilor Foster yes I'd be
happy to add in the uh the uh the
complimentary ones from the emerging
local plan so yes please councilor I'm a
teacher happy with all of this
well I'm not really happy about the
stone walls this plan was drawn up went
to referendum and it was passed uh uh
what's the point having a neighborhood
plan if you're not going to adhere to it
I was just asking whether members wanted
this specific wording regarding the loss
of stone Wars added into the
recommendations to one of the specific
reasons for an acceptability chair I'm
not saying not suggesting that um policy
1816 shouldn't be added in but whether
just that wording members would like
that adding in chair and finally
um it is possible just if we can agree
should the resolution be accept that the
the exact final wording is finalized in
consultation with yourself chair thank
you are people happy with that
yeah thank you okay we have a motion
before us okay just to be absolutely
clear on that then it's to refuse uh the
officer
um the application against officer
recommendations for the conditions or
for the reasons discussed at the meeting
we're focusing primarily on the size
scale design and location of the
development uh with also specific issues
around the loss of um stone walls
um and the relation also to the local
plot also the neighborhood plan uh and
with the final conditions to actually be
drawn up by the planning manager
development Management in conjunction
with yourself is that the essence of a
chair yes okay thank you okay okay now
I'm going to ask for the vote as
explained earlier this is done through a
roll call are you ready Nikki yes I am
chair so um members if you could clearly
indicate for against web saying for the
motion that is on the table
cancer Armitage four
councilor Cooper against
councilor Foster four
Council digget
four
councilor ports
oh
that's the Powell
councilor reader
Ridgeway
against
cancer Rouse against
cancer rough
four
cancer Shipman
against
okay chair that is six boots four five
against with zero abstentions which
means the motion on the table was
carried thank you
when I had indicated a break
so we can either take a break
now or go straight into the second
application
I'll go for a more majority
let's have a break
perfect
um
thank you yeah
uh application number two is Ned 19
forward slash zero zero nine zero seven
four slash ol K low
um before I ask the planning officer to
go through this again
I just asked for the comments and
reports to be produced and the meeting
facilitator will share the presentations
on screen this means I might find it
difficult to see your but present I can
therefore I will allow the officers to
complete their presentation and ask
members to reserve any points of or Draw
questions about the process Until the
End thank you
hey June over to you yeah thank you
chair and first of all may I refer
members to the late update report that
was sent out yesterday and particularly
the additional section 106 requests
received from Chesterfield Hospital
this application chair originally sought
to remove the need for any affordable
housing in connection with the approved
scheme at Calo subsequently though chair
the agent on behalf of the applicants
amended that proposition to reduce
seeking to reduce the level of
affordable housing to 20 now on site in
line with the council's current policy
position
in terms of background share permission
for the development of the site was
granted in 2018 following a resolution
to Grant planning permission
by planning committee in 2016 and that
so that permission chair is Extant
subsequent to that resolution chair the
council's policy position on affordable
housing has altered to the current
requirement as set out in the
publication draft local plan for 20
affordable housing in this location
therefore share as amended the proposal
put forward is now in line with the
council's current requirements
section 106 agreement that accompanied
the permission in 2018 share was based
on a position as at
2014-16 a view of the time that has
elapsed subsequently it was considered
appropriate in view of the applicant's
request to amend the condition to bring
the section 106 agreement up to date two
and that has resulted chair in the
revised requirements are set out in the
recommendation to members the additional
request share that came in yesterday
from Chesterfield Hospital which we get
which will be added to that resolution
share members reminded to accept the
recommendation
therefore chair in conclusion it's
officer's view that the current proposal
is in line with the council's current
position on affordable housing hence our
recommendation to members that the
application is approved share if I can
just go through a few brief slides and
that and now on the screen I've not got
any photographs here as I mentioned at
the site visits yesterday this is purely
an issue of policy principle and not a
site-specific issue just as some
background the area on the SlideShare is
the
application site as say next stamp
permission is in place for that site for
its development for residential
development it is an allocation in the
publication draft local plan chair
if you can go on Nikki please
the application sites as I've said share
outlined in red the area in the blue
land is actually within Chesterfield
Borough so the application site is right
on the boundary of the district with
Chesterfield Borough and you can see the
large number of buildings to the upper
left of the slide that constitutes
Chesterfield Hospital chair with the
associated grounds and car parking the
area immediately to the site
boundary to the north and west is
not Countryside it's Park landing
Association the hospital
site may be developed although the
application was approved and outlined so
further details of its development will
be submitted and considered by the
council and due course whether or not
this application reform members is
approved or not share that to that ends
the comments of officers at this stage
chair thank you thank you
we've only one speaker I believe on this
application
and that's the Charles Dunn
yeah thank you perfectly well
um yeah so we've got a site here that's
languished for several years being hung
upon issues surrounding developer
contributions as you've heard it's a
site that has previously formed part of
the five-year housing land Supply but
it's been unable to actually be
delivered for its intended purpose of a
fairly significant number of new homes
um again as they are doing set out we're
now in a position of having reached an
agreement on the contributions has been
fully tested through the viability
process and is now fully aligned with
with the EU new planning policy and so
on behalf of the applicant
um I just ask that permission coming
granted so they can ensure that this
allocated site can now actually be
delivered thank you
thank you are there any questions for Mr
Dom
Council Shipman
um why why is the um the housing
allocation for affordable homes
preventing the
um the development going forward
previously
because surely at the point in which it
was approved first time around uh the
developer has agreed to meet that that
commitment and surely at that point it
would have been costed in
um that a certain percentages were
affordable houses
yeah I can see why that seems like it
would have been the case at actual fact
that the application previously approved
outline application remained
undetermined for several years long
before I was actually involved in it
um because there was a disagreement
um and between the applicant and the and
officers as to what level of affordable
housing was viable
um in the end it was agreed to Simply to
draw a line under it and to actually get
the approval and get to a point from
which they could actually move on and
and just reassess where they stand so
really the applicant never believed that
that level of affordable housing was
viable
um hence why we we came back in to
discuss things and we've reached an
agreement that happens is now in line
with what the policy is
because I'm struggling with that because
why would you accept the level of
affordable housing that you knew were
deliverable and then come and get an
application outline application on that
proposal knowing full well that you
didn't think it could be the little
developer at the time didn't think it
was deliverable it seems like it's kind
of we'll get it through it and get it
outline approved with some nice figures
um to get the foot in the door and then
come back and find them in slight bit of
it that you didn't like
um
I'm not sure I like the sound of that
it just made sense for them as I say
it was a number of years I'm sure Adrian
can say exactly how many years it was
that if the planning application was
effectively stuck in limbo and it was
mutually agreed between officers and the
applicant to to draw a line under it
um at which point actually as I say
what's being proposed and what's on the
table is entirely in line with policy so
it's almost irrelevant what went before
because it it's it's it's compliant with
the current situation and what recent
viability that's formed part of the new
local plan process determining what
level of affordable housing is viable in
different parts of the district
um it's it's perfectly in line with with
the findings of of your own evidence
base effectively Nicki knows come back
on one last point because the importance
of the affordable housing level of that
town would have been set based on what
has gone before that and if for any new
affordable housing allocation percentage
now is based on the fact that the
previous application might have had a
higher percentage of affordable housing
before Bringing Down the need now
the fact that it was higher and it's now
reduced doesn't mean that you're
necessarily qualified or going to
qualify for lower affordable housing
just because the new policies like that
the fact is that it's like that because
we have had affordable houses in the
past built at a certain level
if that was the case then this site
wouldn't have been taken into account
because it's never been built out
Council of Foster
oh yeah thank you chair my name's uh
councilor Foster uh represent member for
call Aston
um the the viability study you mentioned
uh Mr Dunn is that the financial
viability study is it that's it then
thank you thank you okay are there any
other questions counselor Ridgeway
yeah forgive me but I can't see
um how many houses were initially
approved on this site
and how many of them would have been
affordable housing at 40 please
um I may have to ask the chair to the
first wager on that one as I don't know
I can find out in a few seconds but he
might have it slightly closer to hand
than I do okay
Adrian can you help us out on this one
yeah I appreciate Mr Dunn's confidence
in me chair would I too haven't got it
readily to hand but I'm just trying to
find out for members if you've been with
me a second okay
thank you
the original outline application was for
up to 47 dwellings
um so 40 of that rounded up would be 19
affordable
I apologize I was beaten to each here
but just to remind members the uh the
application was an outline application
chest so that would be that would be
matters that the final numbers would be
matters determined at Brazil matter
stage
so where are where what's the numbers
now is it still remaining at 47
it still would be an outline application
share of up to that number chair so but
that's still the final details would be
determined to reserve Mata stage the
application is merely seeking to amend
condition four of that extant permission
so the permission will remain in place
irrespective of your decision this
afternoon if you reminded to support the
the application it would be an amendment
of that condition and or is set out in
the recommendation share the inclusion
of the requirement for a 20 affordable
housing unit section 106 agreement which
I was deemed appropriate at that point
and whereas if the application were
refused it would still leave the
application extant and it could be
implemented but as it stands it would
have a requirement of 40 affordable
housing okay thank you
it's a major
um it might also be worth pointing out
I'm not sure if Adrian mentioned before
that within the agreed contributions in
the proposed new section 106 there are
additional separate Financial
contributions that weren't actually uh
part of what was previously agreed
um so there's it it is a little more to
it than simply the reduction in
affordable down to the policy compliant
level
thank you any more questions
yes please Chad councilman teach yeah uh
we we often get these uh uh applications
coming in
with all these affordable houses
and uh
then later they want it reducing mainly
because the profitability in uh an
affordable home isn't the same as a on
Market home
now
now we can do these I mean if we did it
fair enough
but are you gonna come back again and
say oh well we can't do it we can't do
it at this and could we reduce it again
I mean are you going to do that
no because the the financial viability
process has already been gone through
with an independent assessor appointed
by your sales as a council
um who have provided advice to to
officers
um so effectively the the whole
conversation's already been thoroughly
worked too from 40 on one side zero on
the other and reach the middle point of
of 20 which
again not to lay with the point too much
but that is what the policy is now
but then you work it through previously
for the 40 percent
it was done and as it explained
um
it was never really agreed before
um hence why it was in limbo
undetermined for for a number of years
um and now we've reached the point where
it is actually agreed and it seemed to
be deliverable and viable on both sides
and so it can actually come forward
entirely in line with policy
but I feel it should have been agreed in
the first place before I started to say
that 40 but anyway that's just my point
of view thank you chair thank you are
there any more questions
thank you Mr Dunn
okay I don't think I need to remind you
all about uh motions if we want to open
the floor to debate first
councilor Foster
all right thank you chair
yeah I don't find this one a hard one at
all uh it states in the mppf that the
only developers entitled to an
appropriate level of profit I know a lot
of people don't like that bit they need
that gross profit to be able to invest
in these uh projects and create jobs so
that normal uh growth development value
is 20 percent
and that and that's what they need to be
able to be financially viable
um they did and I know it's been labeled
a couple of times this point uh
originally I have uh permission for the
40 but that's in the past it's gone now
they're looking for the 20 that 20 that
they want it reducing to is without
current policy
and the black clarification from Mr Kirk
upon this it says and these are the
words I've written down from the mpbf
the percentage of affordable housing can
be lower than the target level of policy
which is our 20 it can be lower than
that Target level of policy if it can be
justified by a financial viability study
this has been justified by a financial
viability study yeah whether you like
what's happening in the past is is one
thing but it's been justified by
Financial viability study so they could
if they wanted to go below our current
policy position of 20 so if I could have
some
an explanation from Mr Kirkham on that
same point since she knows more about it
than I do the recording has stopped
oh
I've got strange messages Alan but never
mind
this meeting is being recorded
I think it's back to normal though yeah
apologies chair uh there are some Wi-Fi
issues here um so I just dropped out the
team it all should be working back up in
life okay thank you councilor reader
and then I'll come back to Adrian
yeah um
I'm just sort of looking at this I've
heard what
housing department and have objected to
the removal of this condition they've
said
um that the Strategic housing market
assessment in the updated in 2017
estimated to me the affordable housing
need for the district there is a need to
bring forward
172 units per year over the period to
2035 or 236 per year over the next five
years Calo is an area with low turnover
properties and a high need and demand
for two and three bedroom homes to rent
so I have to look at it from that term
as well that our own housing department
is saying that we need affordable
housing in Calo so while I appreciate
what councilor Foster's saying I have to
think about what the community needs as
well and they are in need of affordable
housing so I have to be sort of putting
my heart on of saying you know we've got
to do the right thing for Kayla
um and and I don't want to be in danger
of doing the developer's job for making
this viable for them it's for them to
make it viable and if it isn't viable
it's not our job as counselors to do
that for them we've got to set out what
we want for our communities
yeah just in reply to that thank you
chair for me the greatest risk to the
community is that they don't get built
at all if this is not financially viable
and they've understood if it's not
viable for the developer these won't get
built and there'll be no there'll be
less jobs these houses won't get built
and there won't be any one or six money
and when you I know we're checking our
heads but it'll go on current policy
it's not always what we want it's on the
current policy and that's exactly how it
will be uh considered and I'm not
worried that it will go to appeal that's
not a concern but if it does go to
appeal you know it's we've got a clear
policy we can't go against our policy
it's 20 and those houses will get built
yeah Council apparel
yeah I just like to reiterate one of the
points that have already some of the
points are already being made
um
it it is part of the current Council
policy at 20 it's also in the emerging
local plan at 20 percent
the viability process
um has a very specific formula
um which um as has been pointed out is
an independent one and um I'm more than
happy to take independent advice
and the other thing is that um the
developer is being asked to make more
than a quarter of a million pounds worth
of contributions
to various things from Recreation to um
education
contributions as well and that's a
significant sum when you're looking at
the um
the viability of a development
um I um I also take the point that um
councilor Foster made that you know
we need this to go ahead we need these
new homes in Gala
um and that's why I would um I know we
haven't got a motion yet but if emotion
is put forward to approve it I would
support it thank you Chad okay are there
any further
counselor shipment and then I'll come
back to Adrian
thank you
[Music]
um
yes it's
it's that's the new Target based on
what's been approved before
that's the crucial thing
so we're going to set the target based
on the the now demand of affordable
housing not what it was back in 2014 or
whatever it might have been so we have
to look at like now and the reality is
the decision we're taking is would we
have approved this development
with at that point in time 20 housing
affordable housing that's the question
we've got classical solvers I don't
think you would
personally because that was that's what
we were setting at that point in time we
were you know and I don't think we'd
approve it now if that came in with 20 I
don't think
um so I you know they've agreed to 40 uh
affordable housing
councilor readers I absolutely right and
they need to now make it viable whether
that's reducing the amount of the houses
they have or making use a better space
making use better use of the space or
doing something else
um because when developers talk about an
independent viability study anybody
that's ever been wanting their life
knows that you can make it look however
you want it to look to someone that
you're showing it to
it's not as independent as I say it's
not always doing it it's the developer
actually employing somebody to do the
viability assessment so it's about as
independent as as my brother to me
you know what I mean it's it's not it's
not an argument to have I don't think
that this needs to be approved I will be
rejecting it
um or point forward a motion to reject
it
um and keep the housing affordable
housing allocation as is
councilor Foster uh thank you yeah uh
that argument put forward about the 40
is false argument something in the past
we're not being asked to consider that
here you might want to base it on that
but that's not what we've been asked if
you want to argue about that afterwards
you can but it's not about that they're
asking for a reduction to 20 and they're
asking for it now when we look at the
the houses that have been built the the
there are in in the country they're on
the open up if you look at the figures
2018 to 19 we went from 30 000 in that
year to the following year the latest
figures are 19 to 20 to 35
000 an increase of 17 so it's not like
these are getting rejected up another
country more and more of these are
getting built all the time and we need
to do our bit here we need those houses
built here now when it comes to the real
argument is this councilor shipment it
is it's this fact our policy is 20
percent
even if it's 20 a financial viability
study this is what the nppf says which
is what we've got to follow it can be
lower than 20 percent
if they've done one of those studies you
might not put any value on it and it
might be a brother that's done it but
it's a financial viability study and if
we have one and it shows that it's all
about the gross development value which
is normally 20 if it's not then we can
still with our policy and go below the
20 and it's that I asked for a guidance
on from Leicester Kirkham I'm going to
bring Adrian in now
just on that first point chair and
Council Foster is correct and
a number of applicants have come before
the council this committee seeking
actually to reduce the level of
affordable housing well below 20 and
members will recall some of the
discussions we've had in relation to
that over other press committees and
that was primarily the reason why the
study done in 2017 came to the
conclusion that
seeking to achieve 40 affordable housing
on most sites across Northeast
Derbyshire was actually not achievable
even in the even in Good Times hence the
policy that is now embedded in your
publication draft local and the 20
affordable housing with 30 in the the
more viable areas primarily to the the
west and the northwest of the district
the the issue
um is is slightly cloudy by the history
of the application I guess it was
submitted in 2014 a resolution taken in
2016 but the decision wasn't issued
until 2018 as Mr Dunn's outlined and
between 2016 and 2018 actually that's
when the study that now has supported
your current policy was done that was
done in 2017 and the evidence showed
that as I've just said 40 affordable
housing was increasingly unrealistic and
therefore the 20 30 was
um submitted as part of that and just on
the point that um it's an academic point
I guess but just the point that castle
Foster's made with regards to the
application if it was submitted now we
would be coming to members fuel in
simply on the basis as councilor Foster
said of your policy as of now um seeking
a 20 level of affordable housing in in
Calo so
um notwithstanding all of the matters
that would need to be considered on that
basis alone we would be as officers
recommending approve Google left
developers are coming forward with 20
affordable housing in Calo just on the
final Point Chase Allied but it's been
touched on
that the 106 that was resolved to be
approved in 2016 was a lot narrower than
the one that is now before members and
certainly in terms of the education
provision etc those are that's a
situation that's also changed so just as
the applicant has sought to achieve
policy compliance as of now as officers
we felt it appropriate to secure 106
compliance as of now as well that would
lead to the revised 106 contributions
which would actually result in full
compliance full mitigation for social
mitigation on this site which is which
is also unusual
hopefully that helps thank you councilor
Armitage
uh thank you chair I think one of the
things that uh
has been touched on is the fact that uh
if we don't uh go along with this we
could end up with uh no uh no
development whatsoever
uh yes 20 percent it is less and like I
said previously we keep getting these
and they go down and down and down
I wonder if if you know if we go along
with it that we can actually put a stop
on it and say where you would come to
that uh so you're gonna have to stick
with it
the other thing is it's right next door
to the hospital
and there are a lot of people who work
in hospital who are well I won't say
poorly pay well some of them don't earn
a lot of money and these houses okay
only 20 it would attract labor to the
hospital but let's face it they don't
have to climb over the fence and they're
out to work so there won't be any car
parking problems which we all know at
calo it takes about 20 minutes to get
there and 20 minutes to find a parking
place
I would go along with it bearing in mind
that there's a 106 uh agreement there
and it's going to go and a lot of it
will go to the hospital which is solely
needed uh bearing in mind how it all was
stretched at the moment both in the form
of Labor and also uh
well I think it's labor that's the main
place but you've got to have somewhere
for them to live and this would uh fill
the Gap I'm quite sure and I will go
along with it I would like to see 40 but
you know viability and all the rest of
it
thank you chair thank you
are there any more comments
no Adrian do you want to say anything
else
no thank you no okay all right I'm going
to open the floor for a motion
councilor pal
thank you Jack can I move um officer's
recommendation please
can I have a seconder yeah I'll second
it thank you just just on that chair I'm
assuming that councilor Pals moving that
in it with the additional um requirement
for Chesterfield Chesterfield hospital
as of yesterday that's the 103 000 that
was added
okay
are you ready for a roll call then Nikki
I think you chat so this is a motion to
um for officer recommendations
um could you clearly state for against
or abstain how's the Armitage for
councilor Cooper for councilor Foster
for
Council digget for
counterparts
four
cancer Powell
oh
cancer reader
against
Council Ridgeway
the mouse against
Council Bluff
before
Council Shipman
against
so chat with seven votes for four
against and zero abstentions uh that
motion is carried thank you moving on to
item three
which is Ned forward slash two zero four
slash zero zero five three five four
slash FL it's a sighting of 40 at 40
holiday lodges I believe now
no
and I believe
um
councilor Liggett will be speaking this
is a ward member so we'll be
will be leading the meeting until such
times
okay
thank you
I'll pass this over to the planning
officer
hello Susan over to you
sorry Chad just to um
uh just to set advised members I'll go
through the refresh days to do a brief
update but our colleague Sue is in the
meeting room with us and she'll be able
to comment on particularly matters of
fact chair and any other matters that
members may want clarification on okay
thank you just to just to be clear can
share the application now seeks and sent
for 40 holiday lodges chalets for
Holiday use
and The Lodges would meet the definition
of Caravans as set out in the relevant
legislation and add to the existing site
immediately where there is lawful use of
lodges for both full-time occupation and
for an area for storage
provision of leisure facilities chair of
such Leisure facilities would be
contributed to policies of your your
extant local plan but as members will be
aware they would be in accord with the
policy zombie publication draft local
plan and also the more permissive stance
for storage developments has set out in
the mppf therefore share as officers we
consider the proposal in principle to be
acceptable
as set out in the report there will be
some localized landscape impacts that
officers consider this could be
substantially mitigated by landscaping
and of course the development is low
level in terms of its height above any
ground levels
contamination ground conditions drainage
ecology and Highway Safety are all
considered acceptable subject to
conditions chair are set out in the
recommendation
specifically share the issue of proposed
conditions has been raised by the
applicant and this is raised in the late
updates that members received yesterday
and the applicant in that instance is
seeking to have no time limits on the
length of time that the Caravans if they
are permitted could be occupied officers
have taken the view that in order to
meet the policy tests of your
application draft local plan a condition
restricting the length of occupancy to
24 weeks in any one calendar is
appropriate and so avoiding year-long
residency and on that basis chair
offices are recommending the approval of
the application subject to the
conditions are set out in the report and
the recommendation
and just ask Nikki if she'll share the
presentation chair just move on to the
the next slide and Nikki please
as customer chair the application site
outlined
um there in brown the areas directly to
the north of the application site and
the area to the west small area there
they are covered by a lawful development
certificate for
sure correct if I'm wrong but for
full-time residential occupancy and as
you can see part of the site does have
an extant permission for storage of
Caravans and we'll see some photos of
that in a second to the north of the
site you'll be able to see an area of
mature Woodland and just along the
eastern boundary the site is a public
footpath and it's also public footpath
from mickley which is the area to the
South West so the bottom left of that
slide across the fields just below the
site to the farm buildings again we'll
see some photographs of the site taken
from that foot path in a second
thanks Nikki
the application siteshare outlined in
red which is just a wider angle shot of
what we've just seen thanks Nikki
again share the application site
outlined in red with the areas outside
outlined in blue wall so
um under the control of the applicant
thanks Nikki
this is an indicative layout just
showing how 40 Chalet units could be
accommodated on the site the hatched
areas the area I've just referred to
with the lawful uses and occupancy of
Caravans the green area to the left of
the slide chair is an area that would be
left open for recreational use and as
members can see that's referred into the
report the Eastern and Southern
boundaries will be supplemented by
mission of landscaping and the is the
attenuation base in the bottom right
hand corner of the site and again there
are conditions attached to any
permission that may be granted which
would address its design and the
provision of it
thanks Nikki
just now these aren't
um chair photographs of what is proposed
but they're just an indication of a sort
of finish that The Lodges could achieve
so it does show a building in two halves
easily transportable which meets the
definition of Caravans are set out in
the relevant legislation of the next
slide Nikki also shows something similar
thanks Nikki
these uh photographs share taken from
the
footpath that runs along the Eastern
portion of the site and you can see the
mature Woodland in the back of the
society the footpath Disappeared into
that Woodland straight ahead it does
show the Caravan storage that is
extanting has permission already on the
site on the left hand side
thanks Nikki
these are just some photographs share
taken from the foot path and to the
south of the sites showing areas where
there is the extant and lawful use of
shall we occupation on the site already
I think the next photograph similarly
similar view
and I think even the next one no no this
this is
um a more
a wider shot you can see the mature
Woodland in the background you can also
see the lower level nature of the
existing Caravan storage on the site and
the photographs that follow share a
similar photograph showing how the site
is seen in its current context with the
extant permission for storage and then
the Chalet use as well so it shows the
mature Woodland simply to the north of
the site additional Woodland and trees
within the site and then have the
existing address the lawful uses on the
site are currently been operated which
exemplifies the low-level nature of what
is now proposed
thanks Nikki
and again
this is more of a close-up shot of the
the existing Caravan storage area of the
site
I think that may be
the last one yes and actually as I say
um colleague Sirius witness if this
particular issues of clarification that
are needed so as as necessary we can ask
Sue for help and advice
thank you thank you okay
um I've got two speakers for this
application and the recording has
stopped
I'm going to invite counselor Heather
Liggett who's the ward member to speak
on this
can I suggestion meetings is being
recorded in fact ignore what I've just
said it's now being recorded again
apologies Chad there's uh uh just for
anybody who's watching there are some
technical issues in regard to our VPN
network
um which is taking me out of the meeting
and hopefully it shouldn't affect
anything that the public are seeing
thank you councilor Liggett you have
three minutes when you're ready thank
you uh I'm speaking against this purely
and simply and also I'm speaking to the
parish council building simultane
because of the proximity to the toxicity
firstly this is going to be difficult as
you no doubt will ask me for proof which
I cannot give due to this being one of
the countries never mind the County's
biggest cover-ups you are I hope aware
of what has been found at coal light
bowls over well some of the same dioxins
were buried at Stratton after an
explosion the ball's oversight in 1968 I
hope you are also aware in 1992 the nfu
planned to sue co-write as local farmers
had been banned from selling milk eggs
meat and crops due to contamination the
river doli was nearly a thousand times
higher in dioxin than normal this proves
how dangerous these dioxins are I'm
going to read some comments from local
people Lorry drivers of the time from
local historians
in 1972 Cambro contractors buried
contaminate contaminated debris from an
explosion at the balls over coalite
plant it was contaminated with highly
toxic dioxin it was buried in Sherman
Parish but on the Morton doorstep a
County Council tribunal investigating
the long long-term effects of an
explosion in 1958 at bowls over also
Drew attention to dioxins being buried
at Stratton where a former Clay Pit was
owned by Canberra waste products one of
whose directors was the chairman of coal
light some of it was apparently not
buried that deep amidst the rush to Move
It from the balls oversight it's
subsequent to cause a lot of controversy
the actual dioxin field was only a few
yards from the main road very close to a
public footpath across the fields to
midley my own Auntie was nursing
assistant at Morton Hospital in those
years I'm working a lot of nights told
us about the amount of lorries arriving
in the middle of the night I have also
been told some of these Lorry drivers
went in driving the Lorry and came out
on thought in other words the lorries
were buried as well that speaks volumes
I have had this confirmed in the last
few days by one of these Lorry drivers
who told me several boy thought
transport lorries are buried there that
nurse myself in the early 80s we had a
spell of dogs dying who had been walked
in that area
I only hope we can insist on core
samples being taken but even the thought
of that scares the life out of me
disturbing the ground at all doesn't
bear thinking about can I leave you with
a comment from a former colite worker
much of the chemical waste in the past
which didn't go into the tank Farms was
canned and deposited in the South waste
it many barrels of Agent Orange
tcdd were also buried there these are
now greened over a time bomb thank you
thank you are there any questions
councilor reader
yeah I just want to ask counselor Leger
in the conditions and the the planning
officers have put in there
um the no development all commence until
assessment of the risks um have been has
been taken around the land contamination
um and also they've tried to put in
there
um some safeguards to sort of look to
remediate the land if if they do fine
contamination do you feel that that
would give you comfort knowing that that
is in there
um I think it's just what we're talking
about we're not talking about normal
contamination
um it it really worries me because the
environmental health didn't seem
particularly worried but there again
they don't know what they didn't know
what was in there this is what scares me
and when you think about the work that's
had to go off at balls over and the
carbonisation plant you know the the way
that has had to be cleaned to be honest
you know I will put it like this I
wouldn't walk my dog over there and I
certainly wouldn't want to stay in a
caravan as it is at the moment it's been
used for Caravan storage but the
thoughts of people living there for long
periods of time I just find terrifying
and I don't quite know without it
costing Millions I don't know how you
could clean that land up
any further questions
Council Ridgeway
no thank you
no thank you councilor Liggett and we
have another speaker which is the agent
Peter Griffis
hello Mr Griffin
you have three minutes when you're ready
fantastic good afternoon thanks for the
opportunity to speak on behalf of the
applicant in favor of this
um the proposed development which is
supported by the officers the
application site Falls within the
boundaries of an existing and
well-established Caravan site the site
currently accommodates a mixture of
residential and holiday units with the
range between static um Caravans and
larger twin unit lodges all of which
were under the definition of a caravan
are set out in the 1960s Caravan Act
applicant seeks the opportunity to
station additional lodges on the vacant
Fields within the existing Caravan site
as well as changing the use of the
Caravan storage area to site lodges the
applicants aspiration it's a secure
additional lodges is mainly to align
with the holiday market Trend in recent
years there have been a move towards a
longer holiday season with visitors
wanting to stay in holiday destinations
outside the traditional holiday period
in order to meet these demands it's
necessary to provide accommodation which
can be used for greater proportion of
the year
the situation has been exacerbated by
the ongoing covid-19 pandemic with
people now are more attracted to State
occasions
anticipated demand coming from this can
capture can be captured by the proposed
development and in turn provide visitors
with high quality and contemporary
accommodation during their stay
this will have a knock-on benefit to the
local economy in terms of donating local
employment opportunities and increase
their local expenditure within the
region
the application has been well received
by officers of the council and in the
event where concerns have been raised
during the termination process these
have been effectively addressed
examples of this provide additional um
include additional Landscaping to
provide further screening to the
development and in order to accommodate
this led to a reduction from 43 lodges
to 40. and the applicant also agreed to
provide an area of a recreational space
and this will be secured by way of
condition I just like to finish off this
Innovation by addressing the reasons
provided by the local councilor for
calling this application in front of the
committee today
regarding reason one
um service water and drainage
sustainable Urban drainage scheme has
been acceptable by the flood Authority
regarding reason two car parking each
Lodge offers two spaces which is
considered acceptable by the um Highway
officer and in terms of Reason three and
perhaps most importantly
um is the Morton tip the councils are
environmental health officer is not
aware of any evidence remain from any
language they're nation in the area and
has confirmed the application site is
beyond the zone of the influence of any
you know local tip sites
I haven't demonstrated that local
council's initial concerns have been
resolved together with the insuring
proposals are sufficiently screened from
the surrounding Countryside and the
associated positive economic benefits in
line with your offices recommendations
we hope you can approve this application
today
thank you
um I'm going to start the questions
which makes a real change for me
um I just want some clarification please
I was looking at some information
regarding this site online and they're
actually advertising them for sale as
residential Bungalows so
I need some clarification here the
application is for a holiday Lodge
and yet they're advertising them as
residential Bungalows okay well um
currently on site the site already has
permission for a lawful development
certificate for 53 residential
um static caravan Park Homes
um it's usual for them to advertise them
as Bungalows because it's you know it's
a marketing um phrase for them but
they're technically they fall under the
definition of a of a of a caravan
um and yeah this I already has
permission for 53 so that's what the
that's what's being advertised at the
moment
so these 40 are purely holiday
let's that's correct yeah and it's uh
you know the condition
s
councilor reader
yeah can I just ask obviously this and
development is being accessed officially
Lane
um so obviously when you go on to
there's an estate just near near that
and um is very limited in how people can
get in and out of that estate it's one
Road in and one road out so for me it's
obviously if you've got an increase in
the traffic that's going down there it's
the impact on the neighbors and and
things like that that's that's just sort
of concerning me so what sort of
measures are you going to be putting
into place to make sure there's very
limited impact on the people that live
nearby
so in terms of highways
yes please yeah
um well you know there's a condition
that there's um
include a one-way system for example
into the site so the site currently
benefits them to established uh
entrances
um so there'll be an in and out perhaps
um to mitigate against the kind of the
impact of the traffic if you like and
that would help the circulation and the
flow ultimately Lane
councilor Foster
uh thank you chair uh councilor Mark
Foster member for call Austin uh I'm Mr
Griffiths
um it mentions here in the uh page 24 of
our Pike summary of late comments it
mentions that you uh requested for the
being no need for any limitation of the
time for length of stay could you
explain that request to any
metagraphists
yeah of course uh yeah so it was it was
more there was two parts to condition
the first part of the condition
restricts the holiday accommodation only
and in the second part limits that
holiday use to only 24 or so uh 26 weeks
by only one uh person or one kind of
family if you like
um we deal with a lot of these holiday
applications across the whole of the
country and
the preferred approach is just by
securing it simply by holiday use only
um without any restriction to
um the period of occupancy
um this is again a position accepted on
many occasions by the plan inspector
um and it's just a preferred way of
these operators less restriction but
they still have to comply with the
holiday use
but on that there is no definition of
Holland view so if you've got no
restriction uh it's essentially a second
home or it can be your own uh the
primary home of a of someone yeah
well part of that condition would be so
it'd be holiday use only
um and then in order to enforce that
they would have to provide a um proof of
their uh permanent place of residence
yeah I think my question was more more
about uh why you didn't want that
restriction on
it just increases um
maximum flexibility for the occupants
and the owners of these uh new new
holiday lodges maximum flexibility but
thanks for that yeah
any other questions
councilor Shipman
um
I I just wondered um I'm surprised some
of my colleagues don't ask you about it
what Wildlife surveys have you done this
such massive development that you're
doing here because
um it looks big
um is there is there any
you know wildlife and biodiversity
schemes that you've implemented within
this to make it a bit more attractive
um you know what work has been done on
that from
so we've we've carried out all the
necessary uh surveys in terms of the
phase one is to assess the uh the
ecological value on the site
um you'll note there's a condition
um proposed to uh provide uh
biodiversity in enhancements
um prior to any development being
undertaken so at that stage we'll uh
we'll look to provide mitigation
measures to ensure the the equilibrium
value of the site is maintained
okay any further questions
no thank you Mr Griffis thank you
okay I'm going to open the floor to
debate but just to remind you all about
motions at the end excuse me chair is
there any um questions to the officers
at this point Sorry I I'd bypass that
completely I'm looking at the wrong page
are there any questions for the officers
no that's scary okay the floor is open
for you oh cancer Armitage as you signed
up
yeah it's for the debate actually uh uh
I'll let Adrian off for the moment uh it
was uh can I just clarify then have we
moved from questions to the offices now
into debate yeah yes okay that's fine
all right
yeah uh
it's this question of uh
uh contamination uh you know dioxins I
mean the killers and Morton tip is not
very far away
and yes they're saying uh 500 meters
well you know dioxins travel
and is it 500 meters do we know for sure
or else there's been some spillage
elsewhere and without a proper test of
this I think uh on the actual land
contamination
I'm not happy with going ahead with
Grant in it uh
you know bearing in mind what to call
like the explosion that happened there
and stuff being buried there I mean okay
it's hearsay but let's have a proper uh
survey and let's check what the
contamination levels are like including
the water courses uh because you're
gonna put uh all these things on and
there'll be water running off this side
yes into this marvelous settlement thing
which I I did speak to Adrian about and
uh yeah uh I'm not happy until we till
we've had a proper uh contamination uh
uh tests done on this land and how far
it actually spreads uh even if you have
to go and have a look at Norton tip and
see what it's like there because if he
wants most of them on this before you we
deliver any uh decision on this surely
[Music]
I think
uh well I'm mindful of what cancer
Armitage is saying I think we've seen
that there's been really big remediation
um Dawn over the district for sites that
have been really contaminated you know
you look at the Avenue site and you know
there's been lots and lots of work done
and we we have conditions in the report
set down by the planning manager
and the officers that say you know
before any development can commence
you know they're going to have to
produce some sort of assessment and for
me I think that offers a little bit of a
safeguard and a comfort that before
anything can happen they've got to do
that assessment on that risk and so I'm
just mindful of that that we're not just
throwing it out before we've considered
that there is that option of maybe
bringing this land into some sort of
good use rather than it just being stuck
store in Caravans
um you know there is a Housing
Development you know that's right next
to it and there's an estate right next
to it in mickley so with regards to the
tip I don't know that it would stack up
with that if we've got a housing estate
which is literally just quite near to it
so I do think we've got to try and
consider all of those points but I do
take on board all the concerns about the
contamination
thank you councilor Shipman
thanks chair um I I I agree with um
Council armatures that we we need to
develop Safeguard and I think councilor
reader's writing that it's actually in
that condition
um if the only thing where we're
debating is is it contaminated or do you
think seems to be the case to me at the
minute based on what people have said
then that condition for me satisfies
that concert
um and I'd be mindful to approve it and
making sure that we actually do you know
the fear of maybe planning manager
actually do see that uh report so if
there is anything that needs enforcing
or whatever afterwards it can be
um or obviously the approval reason that
it's not a suitable type
um so that's where I'm at um
a motion uh after all the councils are
finished counselor Foster
[Music]
uh thank you chair uh I'm concerned more
about the policies we've got in place uh
specifically local plan policy uh E12
camping and Caravan sites and it says
while it doesn't rule out the
possibility of touring caravan's Heights
in the countryside so this is touring
Caravan sites
and I know it's all about definition
we've got touring Caravans we've got
statistic Caravans we've got lodges it
says while it doesn't rule out the
possibility to turn Caravan sites it
does say that the proposals for new
static Caravans will not normally be
accepted outside settlements
so that's what the local plan says E12
will not normally be accepted outside
settlers and that's mentioned as well on
page 57 of uh our Pike uh 7.2 it
mentions that
at second point the emerging one
and at 7.3 so uh policy wc7
it says the explanatory text to the
policy includes the use of planning
conditions to ensure holiday use rather
than owner occupied second ohms now for
me all of this screams out to me uh
second homes
uh the intention of the uh Mr Griffis
the agent and not wanting that uh that
first clause in even if you put in 24
weeks 24 weeks to me would still say
second homes without shadowed out so
that means the rest of the year it can
be at your own you primary home
uh so straight away so that's two
policies E12 for existing local plan and
the emerging local plan wc7
um
and that that wants to that wants us as
a as a council to steer away from giving
permission for these uh second homes all
the homes I think is entirely different
um this all goes on one step further to
call these and advertise them as lodges
so on one one hand we want to apply the
agents want to apply and the developers
want to apply touring Caravan uh policy
but move straight past static then go
into lodges but advertise them as
something completely different so when
they're advertised on their their open
market these are going through over 200
000 now it's a second home to me we
could argue it's a holiday home you
could that's when you look at the
average cost of a house in this District
on the open market is 187 that's in
Northeast Derbyshire and these are going
at 200.
um
it then States in in 2.4 of our Pike
permission is sought for Holiday usage
throughout the year throughout the year
that's what the permission they want so
basically these are for me these are
second homes if not primary homes
um
so for me it's all put together uh for
me it feels like the developers want to
use our Pulsar E12 which doesn't rule
out the possibility of touring Caravan
site so it says that it doesn't rule out
the possibility to create lodges for
permanent usage at 200 000 a piece
that's what it feels like to me
um let's have a look at the next point I
wanted to make uh this is on the main
modifications so the main modifications
wc6 the most latest one
it says outside the subtle development
limits and Countryside locations
proposals for new or extensions to
existing visitor accommodation whether
whether when it is not used for
permanent residential occupation so it's
so that's what they're not wanting to do
that's in their main modifications
uh let me go further
uh proceeding to that policy wc6
uh there's a paragraph 6.49 in the main
modifications
and this is this was a quite important
one for me so this is the main
modifications visitor accommodation in
rural areas in suitable locations can
have a positive impact on the local
economy
appropriate conditions must be applied
to avoid and then it says this in bold
and underlined unsuitable residential
developments or the provision of
owner-occupied second home so we put it
in our main modifications or the
provision of our own occupied second
homes which are economically less
beneficial and do not positively
contribute to a sustainable communities
uh all of this to me to me points
towards all of it points towards our
existing local plan uh the emerging
local plan and the main modifications
which are there especially that last bit
it all points towards this being it's
these are second homes we've got the you
know it's
that's my piece thank you thank you
councilor reader
I just wanted to say
to see by there's the conditions of
limitations to use and it does mention
in there about each holiday larger only
being permitted to be used as holiday
accommodation and I just wondered if
that offered him any conference at all
with regards to it not being used as a
second home or if he would build
anything extra into the conditions to
sort of relieve his concerns
okay
thank you chair uh thanks councilor
reader
um I think the answer is uh how would
you define a second home uh I don't know
the definition uh and I'd happily take
it from offices uh for me if I lived
here in my house here and I got a second
home on the coast somewhere if I could
afford one would I be spending more than
24 weeks there do you know uh that would
be a second where I spent uh this the
summer there three months in the summer
so for you know it is a second Dome 24
weeks is a second home for me it's not a
holiday let they're not letting it out I
think they're what we're what we're
trying to do in our existing local Plan
and the New local plan what we're trying
to do is encourage the economy a
sustainable economy where people come to
visit we get tourism people come to
visit and they spend money in the local
community this for me is something
different when somebody's got a second
home they will May well Fill the Boot up
before they go there uh from the local
shop go along and they've got it all you
know it's all set up there they're not
people that would necessarily uh go to
visit an area and
be there for two weeks or a month and
then go and visit the local community
and spend money in the local shops and
the visitor attractions these are people
that have got a second home
uh that would just go there and spend
the time there that's that's how I see I
don't know if that makes any sense
thanks
well I'm going to bring Adrian in first
and then councilor Shipman and counselor
richway
I appreciate that chair and um Sue may
have points to make if if appropriate to
but first of all just dealing with the
the contamination issue as has been
mentioned I think by canister reader the
condition that's proposed things
condition three
um it's the one that's been recommended
by the environmental health officers and
would in your officer's opinion address
any concerns about land contamination
requiring appropriate remediation as
necessary should that be required by the
phase one study so as far as
contamination is concerned on the
evidence that's before
um the council that seemed to be an
appropriate way of dealing with the
issue of contamination
just coming on to the issue that counts
The Fosters just discussed about holiday
lodges second homes Etc the application
is submitted for Holiday lodges so it's
not been submitted for second times but
I understand the point that councilor
Foster's making and in terms of that
officers in terms of the most up-to-date
policy in the publication draft local
plan which is in our opinion reflective
of the more permissive policies set out
in the mppf so once in which we would
attach more weight in this case
do encourage touring facilities but
don't seek to encourage second total
just Council Fosters mentioned that was
why I think Council reader raised this
point but I think it's condition 22 does
seek to create a balance on that by only
allowing
occupation with 24 weeks in any 52-week
rolling period it is always difficult to
Define second homes Holiday Homes lodges
how you might Define that and certainly
in terms of enforceability it is very
difficult and you heard earlier on Mr
Griff is saying how he would enforce it
with which would be requiring proof of
first tones my view is that would be
very difficult to Monitor and and
enforce properly and many would see it
as a invasion of their room probably
their their lives that they may not be
happy to cooperate with the Council on
hence our suggestion of 24 weeks in any
role
52-week period however if this was a
concern of members you could impose a
stricter provision on that and for
example suggest no person should occupy
any Lodge for a period exceeding four
weeks in any rolling 52-week periodic
for example which would limit it to
exactly length of time I think the
council Foster mentioned two weeks four
weeks which would
certainly be easier to understand as
holiday use rather than an ongoing
rolling permanent use because permanent
residential use in this location would
generally be contrary to your policies
hence are impositional recommended
imposition of the condition is that fair
enough so as I've outlined it
all right uh yes I think that sums it up
really it's
[Music]
um
it's open to members to come up with a
different condition
um if that was felt appropriate
um really what what we just need to do
is try and
introduce some Precision into the
condition so that it makes it
enforceable
because you just reduced the amount of
time that they're able to occupy the
build it because at that point you're
not going to actually be able to sell a
building if they can only occupy it for
for four weeks or something they're
typically going to be rented out you
know long weekend stays and stuff like
that so I absolutely support
um put in or amending that um
the length of weeks people can stay
there
um and as far as obviously with those
two conditions Bear in mind what kinds
of thought to say I I think that
probably hopefully
um meets the concerns and bills with
them
um so yeah I'm ready
uh yes and I was just going to go along
those lines
um I mean 24 weeks is just over six
months I mean nobody holidays for six
months in one place
um so I think if it is as it states a
caravan Park then it should be treated
as a caravan park for people that a
holiday and I think we should put a
limit of four weeks maximum a four-week
stay
um and
um basically that's in that in that
condition 22.
okay thank you
are there any more comments
any more questions for the officers no
councilor pal
yeah I think um no matter what formula
we come up with in conditions about
um how long people should say it should
stay
in a practical sense and not enforceable
um I just don't think we could come up
with anything that we could be sure of
um my main concern is the potential for
contamination
and I wonder whether I know the
condition says that
um a survey should be done before any
work starts
but I'm wondering whether
we can investigate the potential for
toxic mix in there being sorted out
before we actually Grant permission
maybe that's not practical but
it would seem a sensible way forward to
find out first
um rather than later thank you thank you
councilor Foster
uh yeah thank you chair
um I take the point of the the four week
uh from the other members and
that would that would satisfy my
concerns but I don't think it will stick
uh I don't think it'll be
forcible much like councilor Powell said
so I'm open to suggestions but I've got
the feeling that
you know it could be like other cases in
the permissions granted here and they
come back to have a condition lifted
later on
um and catches light one day
um so that's the feeling I've got
um and I know you shouldn't make
decisions now based on what might have
it happen in the future I understand but
the old intention of all of this is to
build these houses and sell them you've
got to look at the other 53 that are for
sale uh all for sale over 200 000 the
intention is the same here it's second
homes that's the intention
and that's how
you know I think we should bear that in
mind when we when we put anything
forward I think we've got to be I want
to be very careful before I put my hand
up and just saying yeah four weeks and
that'll be fine and they'll treat it as
a uh because I would love these to be I
really would love these to be built and
bring people into our area they spend
money in our area and it create jobs and
an economy they're sustainable it sounds
great and it sounds like really
supportive of that this is not what he's
about that's my concern so I don't want
to rush into this
um that's my thoughts okay if there's no
more comments I'm just going to ask the
clerk to remind you all about uh thanks
harich I think Adrian was wanting to um
make a point I've got counselor her
finger at me
councilor Ridgeway off you go
yeah I just wondered if maybe we could
defer this one uh until
um people's concerns have been uh sorted
regarding the contamination and maybe
finding another way of wording
um condition 22 where we can it can be
enforced I agree with councilor Foster
that I think overall the concept is
really good in the sense that it will
bring people to the area and and I do
believe we need to have these as holiday
alerts but I just wondered whether a
deferment uh may be something that we
could consider
okay
um Adrian yes chair
um
deferment is obviously one option for
members however the the issue of
contamination has come back to the point
I mentioned earlier I do believe that on
that point condition three would ensure
that the issue of contamination was
addressed and if that resulted in
significant amount of work being done
then then so be it but as was mentioned
I think it may have been councilor
reader again but it does show what's
been done on Avenue and and Collide if
you've got sufficient funds you can
provide any technical solution to an
issue such as land contamination so I I
honestly believe that that is acceptable
and could be dealt with by that that
condition three just in terms of the The
Wider use members need to consider
whether this developed in the form that
it's proposed is is that accept or not
in terms of its impact and in terms of
the assessment against your policies
which do allow for
um Caravan accommodation but to serve
tourism the tourism use the tourism
industry and that seems to be the the
issue of concern here I understand fully
the issue that Council Fosters raised in
respect of enforceability and yes
whatever length of time you were to
impose in terms of weeks on a condition
it does raise that issue but
um Sue again may be able to to assist me
on this but it is enforceable albeit it
it does require some some following up
so again if members were concerned about
these facilities being properly tourist
facilities and were concerned about the
length of time that officers are
proposing would want say a four-week
period And I do believe that condition
subject to maybe some some tidying up
application would be precise it would be
enforceable and would serve the purpose
that you would want it to do if you were
minded to to go with that so I do think
it passes the test but I don't want to
underestimate the
um issues around pursuing it from an
enforcement point of view if that were
required but I think again by
conditioning it limiting it to the
length of time that would in my opinion
address the concerns of members and
bring it within line of your policies
thank you councilor Foster thank you
chair are we able to make a proposal
I think at this stage Jay you said this
was still
um the debate or
I was just going to say if there's no
comment no further comment I would
actually put it out for a motion and
I've got a hand going up councilor
Foster
sorry Council Shipman but uh yeah I did
ask first yeah I'd like to make a
proposal easy one uh that we do uh not
give
a planning permission for this based on
those all those uh reasons I mentioned
um the existing local plan uh policy E12
mrkem
E12 it doesn't fit that uh wc6
of the emerging local plan and paragraph
6.49 which proceeds to policy at wc6 the
one about was unsustainable residential
development the one that's in bold
um
which includes the provision of
owner-occupied second homes that's quite
clear that's up to date
um new policy that
uh that I think we're going to be
supporting uh so those those three
reasons uh if anyone uh would like to
add to that
um proposal I'd accept something about
uh
the land contamination but I'd like to
propose that E12 WC 6 and the paragraph
uh in Min modifications 6.49 preceding
that for unsustainable residential
development is that is that clear Master
is that yeah that's that's very clear if
I can just just
um ask for one element of clarification
and I I'm presuming from what you're
saying that you're concerned that isn't
it is in effect amount to the provision
of residential accommodation in a rural
area that's that's the that's the
concern that you have contrary to those
policies but I presume from that point
of view and
residential use would in effect
contribute new Countryside protection
policies anyway and I would suggest that
they were added in if members are minded
to refuse the application on that basis
because I think that is the the thrust
of what the concern would be it it's
just for me please add those in
um
sustainable residential development
um in a Countryside area contrary to
those consolidation policies and then
specifically those I think it's right to
add in um there was tourism related
policies that the council Fosters quoted
chair
I'll second it
okay so we now need a roll call sorry
just to be clear then uh it's to um
and reject the application and not to
give planning permission
um for the reason set out in the
um sort of the discussion here but with
a particular focus on on sustainable
residential development in a Countryside
area
and then if that is past year if the
final wording could be navigated himself
with consultation with yourself which I
think that would allow us to Target any
bits and pieces around that okay is that
okay with you gentlemen
yeah I'd like to also put in the land
contamination
okay does councilor Foster agree to that
uh could have a bit of guidance off Mr
Kirkham how that stands that
foreign
my advice would would not to be include
that because I think there is
appropriate means of safeguarding
the site and its development from that
element of the scheme without
um evidence before you have
extraordinary land contamination I I
understand what councilor Liggett said
at the start but by our own admission
that was I think she used the word
hearsay I I would be very reticent I
wouldn't advise you to include lung
contamination in your uh in your refusal
should be reminded to refuse the
application I I believe that would be
adequately addressed through the
recommended conditions okay I'll
withdraw the land contamination
okay thank you Nikki at the ready
thank you chair uh if members of Kelly
is a four against or abstain
um and this is for uh cancer Foster's
motion to refuse the application cancer
Armitage
for
councilor Cooper abstain
cancer Foster oh
councilor ports for
cancer Powell
four
cancer reader
against
Castle Ridgeway
I'm abstaining
Council Rouse against
councilor Ralph four
and cancer shipment
against
so chair that is five votes four three
against with two abstentions which means
the motion to refuse has been carried
thank you thank you everybody
okay the final application that we have
before us today
I find the right sheet
is Ned
204 slash zero zero nine seven eight
forward slash zero L and this is about
four Bungalows that run ashore
has Council League come back uh oh is
she back
I don't know just give me a moment
[Music]
welcome back Council legit
okay are we all back and ready to go so
it's their final application planning
application
um just again to confirm normal practice
planning for officers will speak first
and the meeting facilitator will put it
all on screen to share it with us so
off we go
is this one you're presenting Adrian
you're on mute Adrian
my apologies on a couple of levels chair
I'm sorry about that
you you're okay me too to start yes
please so just before we begin uh um is
Farnsworth Could you
um disable your camera for the moment
thank you
and on this application change for the
the four Bungalows at um
refer members to the late updates report
of yesterday chair
this application seeks consent for up to
four bungalows in outline with only the
issue of access being considered at this
stage the site is located in the
settlement limits for running short and
on a brown fit for your site as we're
seeing the photographs in a second
therefore an officer's opinion the
principle of any redeveloped on the site
would be acceptable for residential use
in accordance with your policies
the site is elevated above Hague Lane
and currently occupied by a number of
low single-story buildings
for these reasons chairs considered
appropriate to restrict the height of
any buildings to a single story and to
be no more than 6.5 meters in height to
ensure there's no adverse impact on the
character of the air and that's
contained in one of the conditions it's
recommended chair
it's considered the new dwellings could
be designed to not adversely impact on
the amenity of the neighboring
properties in accordance with the advice
of the highway Authority was not
considered to be any adverse impact on
highway safety and therefore share as
officers believe there are no other
technical reasons why consent shouldn't
be granted and recommendation is to
approve the scheme so if I just have the
this slides up Nikki please
thank you
the application site share outlined in
well it's it's colored brown you can
just make out the buildings that exist
on the site we'll see photographs of
those in a second and in the
representations representations is made
on the leilandi trees which occupy the
boundary of the southwestern portion of
the site again we'll see some
photographs of those in a second thanks
Nikki
the application site outlined in red
chair of the land owned or controlled by
the applicant in blue which is the
Bungalow in front of the buildings and
again we'll see the photographs of that
in a second
thanks Nikki
the application is in outline chair but
an addictive layout has been submitted
showing how
for bungalows those of them one two
three four how they may be accommodated
on the side but this is an indicative
layout and detailed approval of sighting
design layout and Landscaping would be
required to reserve Mata stage should
consent be granted this afternoon
thanks Nikki
this Photograph chair looking from Hague
Lane past the existing garage to the
existing Bungalow that's owned or
controlled by the applicant on the left
the buildings that occupy this site are
those
at the top of the well top of the bank
and middle of the photograph the white
buildings currently primarily single
story but there are other buildings
again that will see other structures
that we'll see in a second but it's
primarily those to the top of the site
and then a few others to the right hand
side behind it behind the leylandi trees
on the right hand side
so there's just a few photographs here
that show the site you just go through
the Mickey please
and I think there's another one yes so
it just shows there's a very various
Porter cabins cabins hard standings Etc
on the site and then references made in
representations to these leilandi trees
and the retaining wall that occupies
this portion of the site ultimately they
are matters between the party's chair
but I don't think either issue of the
wall or the trees would
um address sorry create any problems to
the proper
setting of four point blows on this site
thanks Nikki I think we just got a
couple more The Bungalow in the on the
left of this photograph
is the applicant's Bungalow and the
garage in front the the site does slope
down towards uh sorry the the land does
slope down towards Hague Lane so the
application site is the area of the
buildings and the apron of hard
surfacing tarmac in front of it and then
as you can see the site drops down to
Hague Lane so hence the restriction on
the height of the buildings to single
story and or 6.5 meters in maximum
height which officers believe would be
needed to ensure that any development of
the site wasn't over bearing on the the
surrounding area but the the fencing on
the right hand side as you can see is
stepped down which does indicate how the
the land slopes way back down towards
Hague Lane I think there's one more
Nikki
this is just looking North and past the
the application side again you can see
the fence on the the left-hand side the
officer report does say that single
story or Bungalows of room to the roof
is the predominant character of
buildings in the area and you can see
some of those beyond the site to the
north just on the left-hand side of the
photograph I think that's all the folks
perhaps Nikki thank you
thank you
okay we've got uh two speakers on this
and the first one is Samantha Farnsworth
yes good afternoon
um apologies
sorry where have you gone
there we are thank you for your patience
yes no problem apologies I'm not
familiar with this type of process
um and also my
um preparation was in relation to the
um the entire application and I note at
the start of the conversation that the
the chap mentioned that this was about
access my objection doesn't really focus
on access
apart from to say
um I know that there's been
consideration about uh traffic at the
moment I've lived in this house for over
four years during all that time and the
property
um to the south of me which is the
landing question has been used solely
for an office
and there has been no and I I realized
and I recognize that that's a strong
statement to me but to my knowledge no
industrial traffic in relation to this
site at the moment
and so therefore I do believe that the
um the part we're talking about today in
relation to access
um is relevant in so much as there will
be considerable and substantial traffic
um not only when it's been
um the building process is taking place
but also when and if it's actually
developed I do have other concerns but
as I've stated it I I've I've heard the
fact that this is about the access to it
and my other concerns are in relation to
some of the photographs that I've seen
now but unfortunately I've not submitted
that as
um as part of my statement today
thank you you want to carry on you've
got a few minutes left yeah okay so um
in as I've said I apologize and the fact
that the preparation wasn't in relation
to the access and as I've said I've
lived here for just over four years we
appreciate we've not had any neighbors
to the south of us
and when we bought the detached property
we expected a maximum of two sets of
neighbors one either side not a
potential of six
um in an email that I think was wrote
um by Denise Knight to Linda trollope
pointing out that the majority of
Windows point towards 101 and 1038 Lane
and that this could be improved they are
currently no I repeat no transparent
wind is visible from the development
site onto my home at 101 as previously
advised our privacy will be dramatically
compromised as well as the potential
every domestic traffic which quickly
leads 30 seconds Remain the photograph
one of the photographs that's been
um presented I don't believe shows in
pictorial form how steep that gradient
is and indeed 6.5 meters is very high
and the people in those houses will
clearly be able to see into my property
thank you okay have we any questions
no thank you and the next uh speaker is
the agent Linda trollope
foreign
you're ready
site is located within the settlement
development limit for Renshaw and is a
previously developed site having been
used for commercial purposes original
Sawmill and most recent years offices
and storage for two building
construction companies
is in a sustainable location with easy
access to local services and public
transport services
the principle of the Redevelopment of
the site is in accordance with both
local and National planning policy
this is an outline application which has
been submitted to establish the
acceptability of the Redevelopment of
the site for four bungalows
and while a layout plan has been
submitted with the application this was
for illustrative purposes only and does
not indicate the final layout of the
site
full details of the site layout the
appearance and scale of the Bungalows
will need to be submitted as a reserved
matters application if outline
commission is granted
and the details of the scheme considered
at that time that would be the
appropriate time for considering matters
such as the detailed impact on neighbors
privacy Etc
the only detail that is under
construction under consideration with
the current application is the site
access
the access will follow the line of the
existing access apart from a small
deviation close to the highway to
improve visibility and allow space to
provide pedestrian into visibility space
to either side of the access
the success serve the former commercial
uses on the site
which involved heavy Goods vehicles and
up to 12 employees frequently traveling
to and from the site several times a day
traffic generated by four Bungalows is
likely to be significantly less than the
previous commercial traffic and I would
also stress that the highway Authority
is your technical advisors have raised
no objections to the use of this access
view of the above I would request that
members should accept the planning
officer's recommendation
thank you are there any questions
I'm Sorry Miss Farnsworth you can't
speak anymore now you're not party to
this
um no questions
thank you very much
are there any questions for the officers
councilor Ridgeway
yeah I noticed in the photos that nobody
actually took a picture from the main
road itself from the other side of hayg
Lane viewing up to where these how these
Bungalows are going to be
um I am 100
um against
um these in the sense of the um
the the road and
and that I've got concerns regarding
the visual side of things it's quite
that must in more Road cannot have
Pavements either side it cannot be made
pedestrians safe at all
and it is is a bit of a rap race as well
and we have big lorry we have bus routes
we have
uh big lorries coming from bowls over
coal lorries
um it's it's just not sustainable and
you cannot
um
have that road cannot have all these
cars coming in and out of that entrance
on a daily basis and you're probably
talking about probably eight to ten cars
extra for that area and the road is just
not wide enough as far as I'm concerned
for that access to be to be looked at
for these bungalows
any other questions comments
no Adrian can I bring you in now
just in terms of the the issue that
um cancer Ridgeway raised about highway
safety chat
the the highway Authority as members
will note have raised no objections to
the application and
as Mrs trollope says they are the the
advisor to the Council on that so I wish
them in an office of you carry
significant weight in your consideration
and as we've discussed many times at
Committee in terms of Highway and other
related issues is the evidence of the
impact that needs to be considered and
whilst noting what accounts the Ridgeway
said for
Bungalows wood um on the basis of the
normal assessment by the high Authority
result in potentially 24 traffic
movements over a 24-hour period of which
and 15 would be in the Peaks that six
traffic move traffic traffic movements
in the peak hour which is one every 10
minutes which
um from an officer point of view we
wouldn't consider had a serious and
adverse impact on highway safety so
bearing in mind the the issues before
you the advice of the highway Authority
and the likely impact of the scheme on
highway safety I don't believe as
officers we will play significant
concern on that element and you also
need to bear in mind that the site has
an extant commercial and Industrial use
that could be reintroduced at any time
and that too would have
traffic and Highway implications maybe
even greater than for bungalows so I'd
also ask that members take full account
of the fallback position in terms of
that Highway issue
thank you chair
thank you
any other questions comments for the
officers councilor Armitage
thank you chair uh I'll take it as in
the now so it's a Brownfield site as it
is
Adrian yes yeah yeah so the the
buildings on and the uses that um Mrs
trollope mentioned chair yes it is a
Brownfield psych as you can see the area
that's proposed carries existing
buildings and the tarmac apron in front
of it
I think myself that uh
uh
there is a problem here with privacy for
the existing uh people but uh I think to
sort of Tide you the site up uh will be
a good idea uh by putting some houses in
but limit the height uh so limit the
impact of them
and also limit the fact uh about putting
Dormer windows in but this can come into
the reserve matters so
yeah I'm in favor of this uh application
okay are there any more comments before
cancer shipment
Adrian can you just clarify for this
absolutely right this is when are we not
are we able to add conditions
um to mitigate the concern of the object
which was the viewing into the windows
thing when we actually apply conditions
to this application here to say put up a
you know like um some some fencing or
something that could were high enough to
mitigate that view
if you're so concerned about it and
otherwise and you would wish to
resist the application of that reason
then yes you are you could require say a
two meter fence along a rear boundary
for example that would normally come in
as part of partial Reserve matters
scheme that he was so concerned about it
then you could impose that condition now
what you need to be precise and where
you would want it and the reason for it
the the issue that cancer reality has
made
um in terms of the removal of that I
think Captain is talking about removal
of permitted rights
to prevent things such as normal Windows
being added the impact on neighbors is
isn't material matter and officers
believe that Bungalows or
dwellings no higher than 6.5 meters in
height or could be designed to protect
Humanity despite the changing levels and
for that we need some condition number
three is to restrict the buildings to
single story with a height no greater
than 6.5 meters to the highest Ridge
Point so that that's that particular
issue but again if the concern of
members was into potential introduction
of dorm or Windows subsequently then
even at this stage if you wanted to you
could remove rights for Dormer windows
additional alterations to the roof
manual door so even at this point remove
any rights for the recently introduced
additional story on top
um even at this point you could remove
that right
it's not recommended currently neither
the issue about the boundary fencing
that cancer Shipman mentioned or the
rule of PD rights that councilor
Armitage has mentioned but you could
impose that at this stage if you felt
there was a good reason
well I understood the opinion if we
mitigate this I mean the Bungalows are
high so even though you're restricted to
one level there's still looking down
um into into Windows which I'm just
thinking
um it might be something that we could
condition so that the developer puts
along that western boundary as it backs
onto those that
107 and 103 is it
I think um like my suggestion chair that
condition is added requiring a enclosure
means of enclosure whether it be a fence
or a wall a two meters high along the
the western boundary
only to allow the access road to be
afforded through it yeah I'm happy to
leave it to the developers to choose
what they feel is necessary but I think
there does need to be something that
that
gets rid of that line of sight I think
down down the hill towards 103 and 107.
um
so yeah that's that's my views and then
with that condition I'll be in favor of
um proven it to be honest Council
Armitage
thank you chat yeah uh
I think
surely that uh if we take the uh build
the buildings away at the moment and if
you because of the height I just wonder
if we stuck a bulldozer in there and
scraped a lot off you could reduce it by
a couple of feet something like that
which would reduce the impact on the
other houses uh I mean count at this
point can we say excavate because you
could level it off more let's put it
like that
and also uh put the provision in uh for
a single story no Dormer windows uh and
reduce the uh actual pitch of the roof
uh to a small amount so that people
can't go and uh probably uh Velux window
in and a second story
could it be done at this point
if you considered it necessary yes that
could be done as I say condition number
three currently restricts the dwellings
to be single story in height and single
story with height no greater than 6.5
meters is the highest point of the ridge
you could
um if you wanted to reduce that 6.5
height you could do that I don't know
what that would be and how stupid would
need to be to accommodate a roof roof
tire but if you considered 6.5 meters
was that that's acceptable you then take
away rights to install Dormer windows
and any other alterations to the roof
and you could remove any rights to
install their looks or similar roof
lights as well and you could do that at
this stage if you felt that was
necessary yeah could we actually uh
restrict the you know excavate these uh
the ground level out uh sorted to
uh scrape the top off and reduce the
height to start with the side by a
couple of feet
I I don't know if that would be
reasonable because I don't know the
implications of that and how that will
impacts on other things I I think if
you're concerned about the height you
could either wait the reserve matters
application
to come in or you could specifically
require details of the reserve matches
to include the levels and then you would
have the opportunity of assessing the
levels of the new buildings on the agony
properties at that stage but I think a
levels condition specifying those
details to be part of the reserve
matters would be one way of ensuring
when the reserve matters come in you
would have that information to be able
to make that assessment that would be my
recommendation chair that
um you impose that level's condition and
also and view your cash armor to use
concerns members would
committed rights or Dormers and any
other alterations or Windows in the this
stage as well which would then educate
any reserve matters submission
thank you councilor pal
um yes thank you chair I think we're
getting a bit ahead of ourselves here
I think I think all those matters can be
dealt with
um at a later time when we have specific
details on what's proposed at the moment
we only have four bungalows in outline
um so I um I think that um
I'm sure the agent has been listening to
our conversation
and we'll get a drift of what um of what
our concerns are and I hope that would
be reflected in the eventual full
application
um so I um I I will fully support this
when the motion is given It's Made
thank you if there's no further comments
I will open the floor for motions
um I'm going to ask oh councilor
Shipman's waving his hand
sorry I'm I'm up its way to for you to
finish what you're about to say I was
just going to ask the clerk to uh go
through the rules and regulations
regarding motions
yes you just bear me off your second
chat
yes should remind members that uh to
bear in mind that emotion must be moved
and seconded before the votes taken and
if an amendment to a motion is
subsequently moved and seconded then
that Amendment will be voted on first
uh and just again to remind members if
emotion is to move which goes against
officer recommendations and the members
move the motion must give the reasons
for doing so
um thank you chair okay do we have a
motion on the table yeah I'll put one on
to go no absolutely
councilor shipment how do you signed up
first sorry
um yeah I'll propose that it's accepted
on the basis though that there's there's
a condition in there to um
what a two meter high fence along the
western side of the Bungalow boundaries
which runs along 103 and 107.
of the of those two Bungalows there so
basically it would cut off the visuals
down the hill
and along along the entrance pathway so
that the the concerns raised by it the
objective to me that that's met
I see no other Banning reasons why this
can be objective but anyway
okay is there a second there for this
yeah I'll second it
thank you councilor Armitage
Nikki are you at the ready
yeah
so
um
before you take the vote just so so I
can be absolutely clear the the
resolution is
um as per set out in the officer report
without additional condition from
councilor Shipman regarding a two meter
high boundary on the western a two meter
high fence or similar on the western
site boundary
yeah I mean would it make it easier just
to put wherever there's a balancer with
a resident so I know there's only one
side that backs onto the field so it
would be all the other boundaries wanted
to because that's what visuals would be
yeah
if I understand it correctly chair then
a two meter high boundary uh fencing or
Walling or similar on
um the southern Western and Northern
site boundary
yeah
both happy with that gentleman
well um yeah thanks
are we okay to go now Alan uh yes chair
thank you off we go Nikki okay thank you
members if you clearly uh say fought
against or abstain for a motion that's
on the table to meet the recommendations
with a condition cancer Armitage for
counselor Cooper for
Council Foster four
Casa Liggett or
counterparts oh
cancer Powell oh
cancer reader
for
there's a Ridgeway
I'll go for it
Council brass or
cancer rough four
Council shipment oh
chat with 11 votes four zero against
zero absentions that's carried
unanimously thank you thank you very
much
and I think the final item on our agenda
is the planning appeals uh calling the
planning manager to explain our next
report item nine appeals lodged and
determined
that's a not a great deal to go into it
in this month's report yeah there's been
the two appeals one allowed and one
dismissed the decision notice has been
forwarded through to members and as as
one relates to a bungalowic Greenlee and
dronfield and the other are two-story
dwelling at Rotherham Road in in killer
Marsh but they do make quite interesting
reading as they aren't um in an officer
or of perspective entirely consistent
with one another they don't raise some
significant matters of policy or
principles so no further
um comment to make here although as with
all appeal decisions they do when do
make some interesting reading
thank you okay is everyone does anyone
have any questions
no we're all happy to accept the report
just to show if hands will be fine
I guess that's accepted Joe
thank you
um
last item item sends urgent business I
don't have any urgent business but I do
have a bit of an update regarding
training as you're all aware we've been
hoping to have someone from highways to
come and talk to us regarding on how
they work unfortunately we've not had
any luck to date
um but I have been informed that they've
now had a reshuffle over at County
regarding highways and in the not too
distant future we will have someone to
come and do it with
I would ask for members is if you have
any Pacific items for training you get
in touch with me via email and also if
you pass that and copy in the councilor
Foster that would be brilliant thank you
very much for your forbearance and I
wish you a good night thank you